Das war's für heute und wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal wieder, bis dahin, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss.
Das war's für heute und wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal wieder, tschüss, tschüss.
Das war's für heute und wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal wieder.
ist ja noch nicht zu voll. Ich habe weißes Design. Was habe ich? Im Light Mode? Ne. Achso,
ich habe halbe halbe. Ich habe die Leiste und den Kram in Dark und die Fenster in Light. Ja,
das stimmt. Ne, mache ich nicht. Das sieht unter Windows nicht gut aus. Beziehungsweise,
was heißt nicht gut aus? Das sieht an sich eh schon nicht gut aus, aber ich finde,
das ist in Windows nicht gut umgesetzt. So, wir machen mal die VM an. Also,
wir machen heute eine Web Anwendung. Pepofetter, die Random Gerichte oder Random Essen generiert
und Bilder davon anzeigt. Also, ich weiß es. Wahrscheinlich werde ich GoLand verwenden.
Mal gucken, wie wir das machen. Also, Chat, wichtigste Frage. Was nehmen denn die coolen
Go Leute für Web Anwendungen und für Datenbanken? Also, für Web Anwendungen habe ich letztes Mal
gefragt im Stream und da war so 50-50 oder sagen wir mal so, es war ein bisschen mehr,
aber viele Leute haben gesagt Standardlip und andere haben gesagt Fiber. Was ist denn cooler?
Was ist denn mehr im Trend? Also, wo kann man besser mit Posen, wenn man es kann? Fiber oder
Standardlip? Ich meine, für das, was wir machen, ist Standardlip wahrscheinlich absolut
ausreichend. Ich meine, das gibt ehrlich gesagt, das gibt wahrscheinlich einen Endpunkt oder so,
Random Rezept. Ich meine, für einen Get-Endpunkt brauche ich wahrscheinlich keine Library. Aber,
wie gesagt, wir müssen da mehr machen. Also, wir müssen erstmal eine SQLite-Datenbank erzeugen mit
Rezepten drin und dann, wobei, wir könnten das auch per API-Aufruf erzeugen, irgendwie die Rezepte
oder so. Aber ich will es ehrlich gesagt lieber in die Datenbank schreiben, weil ich dann mal
gucken kann, wie man SQLite in Go gescheit verwendet. Ich weiß, dass es lange Zeit etwas
problematisch war mit SQLite in Go. Also, nicht für sowas wie ich mache, sondern für so wirklich
High-Performance-Dinger, weil Go lange Zeit ziemlich in Offerhead hatte, wenn du C-Interop
gemacht hast. Mittlerweile ist es wohl besser, aber noch nicht ganz toll. Super Eats. Ja,
Gorm. Gorm habe ich auch gesehen schon. Oder Go. G-O-R-M. Naja, eigentlich, okay, das ist ja der Gag,
dass es O-R-M ist und Go, also Gorm. Ja, ja, ja. C, also es muss nicht C sein, aber alles quasi
mit, wie nennt man das, diesem C-Call-Interface, also der C-Style, wie man Funktionen aufruft,
also das, was so ziemlich so, wie jede, jede Programmiersprache kann, um mit jeder
anderen Programmiersprache zusammenzuarbeiten, ist in Go nicht so einfach. Wenn du von Go,
genau, mit C-Go-Bindings haben die da irgendwas gemacht, also wenn du von Go C-Libraries oder
C-Funktionen aufrufst, dann ist das langsamer, als wenn du Go-Funktionen aufrufst, weil C-Go
Gedöns macht, keine Ahnung. Was aber noch viel schlimmer ist, ist, wenn du Callbacks hast von C
nach Go, da muss das ganz langsam sein. Also ganz langsam, also da reden wir von ein paar Nanosekunden
oder so, was so ein normaler Funktion-Call braucht zu, naja Millisekunden nicht, aber schon deutlich
mehr, also es ist irgendwie tausendmal langsamer, als irgendwie eine Go-Funktion aufzurufen. Da
gibt es ziemliche Probleme. Hey, ich habe einen Windows XP. VM, aber der Sound ist kaputt seit VM,
wer geht, VM Audio nicht mehr, keine Ahnung. Ich habe, glaube ich, noch nicht 16.2. Was ist
denn VM Audio Back? Das kenne ich gar nicht. Zeig mal, was ist VM Audio Back? Workaround
for VM August Audio Distortion. Ach Windows, okay, das Problem habe ich mit der Linux VM
wahrscheinlich nicht. Braucht man da überhaupt einen Workaround? Ja, da bin ich mir auch nicht
so ganz sicher, ob die den Overhead auch haben oder nicht. Es könnte ja sein, dass die den nicht
haben, weil die auf irgendwelche zusätzlichen Absicherungen verzichten, weil sie sagen, das
haben wir selbst gebaut und wir wissen, dass wir keinen Mist bauen. Also ich habe da mal,
ich habe da mal über diese ganze C-Gaur Geschichte, ich habe da mal einen Konferenztalk drüber gesehen
und eines der Hauptprobleme oder eines der Hauptperformanceeinbußen, wenn man von Go C
aufruft oder vor allem, wenn man von C Go aufruft, ist wohl, dass die irgendwelche Logs machen
müssen, dass du im richtigen Thread landest, weil du könntest ja beispielsweise, dann könntest
ja C aufrufen, dort einen Thread starten und von dort wieder in Go callen und dann kackt Go
im Zweifelsfall ab. Und das wollen sie nicht und dementsprechend machen sie irgendwie zig
checks, wenn du Callbacks in Go, ob du im richtigen Thread bist und haben irgendwelche Logs und
alles mögliche. Man kann diese Sicherung allerdings auch nicht abschalten, das ist das,
wie gesagt, das ist jetzt alles nur von diesem Talk, den ich mal vor zwei Jahren gesehen habe,
also wie genau ich das noch im Kopf habe und ob das noch so ist, sei mal dahingestellt. Leider
gibt es wohl keine Möglichkeit, das abzuschalten, so nach dem Motto, ja ich weiß, ich sorge dafür,
dass ich im richtigen Thread bin und kein Mist calle. Naja doch, man braucht das manchmal. Also
jetzt, wir brauchen es nicht, weil wahrscheinlich der SQLite Rapper oder was auch immer das schon
für uns macht, aber ich habe mal eine Go Library gerappt, dass ich sie von.NET aufrufen konnte,
nämlich die hier, guck mal. Go hat nämlich so ziemlich die einzig brauchbare WebRTC-Implementierung
für Serverseite, wenn man nicht gerade die offizielle C++-Geschichte verwenden will.
Und das ist wirklich nice, wenn man mal WebRTC machen will, haben wir glaube ich sogar im Stream
schon verwendet und da mussten wir Go aufrufen von.NET, also im Prinzip mussten wir Go Funktionen
exportieren mit einem C-Interface zum Callen und ich sage euch Leute, wir haben es damals ausprobiert,
es war schon eine ganze Ecke langsamer als Native Function Calls, allerdings jetzt nicht in der
Größenordnung, dass es unbenutzbar wäre. Hat sich, es hat sich aber bestimmt auch,
es hat sich bestimmt auch einiges da getan die letzten Jahre. Ja, SQL kann schon immer in
Memory Database, allerdings ist die glaube ich limitiert standardmäßig auf 2 Terabyte,
2 Terabyte wäre es jetzt, ich glaube das wäre kaum eine Limitierung. Auch 2 Gigabyte ist das
glaube ich limitiert. Ich glaube Go in Memory Database kann maximal 2 Gigabyte sein. So,
gehen wir mal in die VM. Aha, Leute gibt es Sonnenblumen, Pog. Moment Leute, habe ich die
VM neu gestartet oder war die schon gestartet? Ich habe die neu gestartet, das heißt heute ist
Bing Image of the Day Sonnenblumen. Ja, wir lernen Go, beziehungsweise ich frische mein Go mal ein
bisschen auf. So viel habe ich damit noch nicht gemacht, ich kann den Kram lesen, ich kann damit
auch ein bisschen was schreiben, aber ein bisschen was größeres. So, Updates, Go Land, ist das schon
alles, habe ich schon alles geupdatet, Go Land 2022.1.3. Das sieht ehrlich gesagt ziemlich gut aus,
warum ist Rider nicht aktuell? Was ist da los? Max, bist du auf Linux? Ja, bin ich und pass mal
auf und jetzt bin ich wieder auf Windows. Hä, warum? Ich habe mir den ganzen Chatbrains Kram gekauft,
warum soll ich dann Visual Studio Code verwenden? Wie das? Guck mal, es gibt verschiedene Desktops,
kannst du mittlerweile machen seit Windows 10, auf jeden Fall vielleicht auch schon seit Windows 8,
du kannst verschiedene Desktops machen und dann machst du einfach eine VM im Fullscreen auf
Desktop 2 und dann switchst du mit Tastenkombination zwischen Windows und Linux hin und her. Du kannst
alles machen, was du willst unter Linux, außer, außer Hardware Zugriffe, also GPU Decoding und
so ist da nicht. Wie alt ich bin? Ich bin 37. Also ich bin Massive, pepo old. Ja, ist so.
Die Frage kommt oft. Die Frage kommt so oft, dass wir da sogar extra schon einen Clip für haben.
Die Antwort, ganz kurz, dass du den Clip nicht angucken musst. GPU, nee, kannst du nicht, kannst
du nicht. Ganz kurz, also ich habe mir das angewöhnt und die Angewohnheit habe ich schon
jahrelang und ich wüsste auch nicht, warum ich mir wieder abgewöhnen soll. Also du kannst die
GPU nicht durchreichen, das funktioniert nicht. Nein, GPU Pass-Through geht nicht. Vor allem bei
Workstation unter Windows kann keine GPU durchreichen. Was du machen könntest, ist Hyper-V oder so
verwenden, wobei ich mir nicht sicher bin, ob das Hyper-V unter Windows 10 GPU Pass-Through kann.
Du könntest Linux als Host nehmen, GPU Pass-Through machen und Windows virtualisieren,
wobei du dann wieder andere Probleme hast. Also für mich ist diese Setup hier mit Abstand am
besten. Ich habe mittlerweile um die sieben VMs ungefähr, die ich regelmäßig verwende.
Also die hier meine ich jetzt nicht. Das sind ja so ein paar Testdinger, die wir mal im Streaming
gemacht haben. Ihr werdet es nicht glauben, aber die Qt4M verwende ich nicht regelmäßig. Weil
ihr seid, Chat, eine Runde für euch heute nochmal. Qt4M. Zehn Sekunden, länger halte ich es
wahrscheinlich nicht aus, aber muss mal wieder sein. Okay, Qt4M, genug Qt gewesen,
wieder aus, next. Bin ich denn stehen geblieben? Chatbrains ist der Hersteller. Chatbrains ist
der Hersteller. Chatbrains macht mehrere Tools, unter anderem machen die auch IntelliJ und PyCharm
und Rider und wo haben die denn hier eine Übersicht? Das hier ist so mehr oder weniger der ganze Kram,
was die haben. Webstorm, haben wir irgendwelche Webstormers bei uns im Chat? RubyMine habe ich
vor Jahren mal verwendet. Rider für.NET, PyCharm, Python, Web, PHP, Java, Gedöns, Go,
ihre Visual Studio Code Konkurrenz, Dataspell, Datacrypt, keine Ahnung, C und C++, Rust Plugins
haben sie. Was ist denn Rider Flow? Ist das irgendwie Unity? Das ist irgendwie ein Unity
Zeug. Das muss irgendwie ein Unity Zeug sein. Wieso machen die nicht eine IDE für alles?
Wahrscheinlich, weil das nicht so einfach ist und sie versuchen ja gerade Fleet zu, ich
weiß gar nicht, wie da der aktuelle Stand ist. Ich habe von Fleet schon länger nichts
gehört. Das versuchen sie gerade. Also Fleet ist wohl standardmäßig ein ziemlich basic
Text Editor, den du aber mit Plugins zu allem möglichen aufbauen kannst. Nee, Rider ist
nicht für alles. Rider ist für.NET. Du kannst IntelliJ ziemlich aufbauen, aber ich glaube,
.NET kannst du nicht in IntelliJ machen, oder? Also du kannst, ich glaube, das kannst du
auch nicht alles installieren. Du brauchst glaube ich IntelliJ Ultimate oder sowas. Ach,
kein Schimmer. Ist mir wurscht. Also ich verwende von denen Sea Lion, Go Land und Rider und
ab und zu PyCharm. Und Sea Lion auch noch relativ selten, weil ich mache großen Bogen um C++,
aber manchmal kommt man halt nicht drum herum. Also das ist der Hersteller. Ja, und jetzt
wollen wir mal was zur GPU Pass-Thru. Das funktioniert nicht. Und selbst wenn du sagen
würdest, du virtualisierst das Umgedreht, also du virtualisierst Windows unter Linux,
dann musst du andere Probleme lösen. Was davon ist für C Sharp Rider?.NET. C Sharp
ist quasi so die Haupt.NET-Programmiersprache. Du hast noch sowas wie F Sharp und du hast
auch noch sowas, ich traue es mich kaum auszusprechen, du hast auch noch sowas wie VB.NET und sowas,
wobei das eigentlich nicht Pippo Hens ist, das ist eher so. VB.NET, ich glaube VB.NET
weint keiner nach. Keiner weint, wie auch immer, weint VB.NET nach. Ja, genau, aber
hier nochmal zu der Virtualisierung. Also selbst wenn du jetzt sagen würdest, man macht das
umgedreht. Man virtualisiert Windows unter Linux oder Linux hauptsächlich drauf. Selbst
dann hast du Probleme, die du lösen musst. Zum Beispiel, wie machst du das, wenn du
GPU Pass-Thru machst mit deinem Hostbetriebssystem? Dann bräuchtest du ja zwei GPUs, also für
dein Hostbetriebssystem und für die durchgereichte GPU. Oder du machst sowas richtig abgedrehtes
wie Hyper-V und diese Nvidia Grafikkarten-Partitionierung. Fragt mich nicht, wie der Kram heißt, vielleicht
weiß es einer von euch. Es gibt von Nvidia in ihren Workstation-Server-Grafikkarten gibt
es so die Möglichkeit, quasi die Grafikkarte zu teilen zwischen mehreren VMs. Da gibt es
so eine, das kostet Tausende, das ist CRIT. Ja, ich glaube CRIT kann sein, das ist aber
richtig teuer. Also du brauchst quasi zwei GPUs, es sei denn, und das ist das nächste,
wie gesagt, es gibt ja für die meisten Sachen irgendwelche Lösungen. Du machst solche Sachen
wie Looking Glass oder sowas, also du kopierst dann quasi die Frames von der VM auf den Host
und sowas. Aber ganz im Ernst, der Einfachheit halber ist mir das so deutlich lieber und
ich brauche nicht für alles irgendwelche Workarounds, weil ganz im Ernst, ich verwende
zu bestimmt 60-70% hier daheim Windows einfach für Steam, Videoschnitt, Geschichten und
sonst was, Video Capturing und alles mögliche. Und wenn ich irgendwas programmieren will
oder wenn ich irgendwas basteln will, dann switche ich einfach auf Linux. Also für mich
ist die Kombination aus Windows als Host und Linux in der VM vom Handling her das Beste,
das heißt nicht zwangsläufig, dass es für euch das Beste sein muss, aber ich finde das
Setup gut und ich finde es für mich oder insgesamt ehrlich gesagt besser als Windows unter Linux.
Windows unter Linux kann man machen, vielleicht wenn man sowas hat wie meine Steuersoftware
läuft nur unter Windows und ich benutze das Ding einmal im Jahr oder so, dann vielleicht,
aber ansonsten würde ich es nicht machen. Also wenn man alles hat was unter Linux gut
funktioniert und man braucht ab und zu mal was unter Windows, dann eine Windows VM, ok
das kann man machen, aber schön ist was anderes. Ja aber was du damit nicht hinkriegst sind
zum Beispiel GPU Decoding und sowas. Also wenn du Videos guckst, es hat alles seine
Tücken, es gibt für vieles Workarounds, die es aber im Handling her ekliger machen. Dual
Boot ist allerdings das letzte was ich machen würde. Gibt ja Leute die sagen noch ja ja
ich will auf Linux umsteigen machen, aber mach mal du. Ne also Dual Boot ist wirklich
das letzte was ich machen würde. Dual Boot ist eklig. Ich kann es auch nicht verstehen
wie die Leute das auf ihre Mac sich antun, so ab und zu mal in Windows booten um da was
zu machen und dann wieder zurück in Mac. Also das würde ich nicht aushalten. Dual Boot
ist ja wirklich bescheuert. Du musst viele Sachen doppelt haben auf beiden Betriebssystemen,
ja von Instant Messenger, E-Mail und sonst was, weil vielleicht bist du immer 3 Stunden
in dem einen Betriebssystem willst deine Mails nachgucken, Instant Messenger. Ja du musst
vieles doppelt machen und immer dieses Zwischendurch an und ausschalten ist auch nervig. Also
Dual Boot ist abfuck. Also Dual Boot würde ich nicht machen. Ich würde immer gucken
dass ich das was ich brauche virtualisiert krieg. Einzige Plattform die man schlecht
virtualisieren kann ist Mac OS. Also wenn man jetzt sagt ich möchte gerne alle 3 Betriebssysteme
verwenden, dann bleibt dir eigentlich nur die Möglichkeit den Mac zu kaufen und darauf
den anderen Kram zu virtualisieren, wobei ich mir da auch nicht sicher bin wie gut das
unter neuen Macs funktioniert, seitdem wir nicht mehr Intel CPUs drin haben. Da bin ich
aber überfragt wie gut das tut. Ich mach keinen Dual Boot. Ich hab ne VM auf dem zweiten
Bestop. Warum kann WebStorm das gleiche wie PHPStorm? Ich dachte PHPStorm ist halt für
PHP und das hier ist für Javascript gedönst. Ja IntelliJ ist glaube ich echt das beste
für Java. Haben wir noch irgendwelche Eclipse Benutzer hier? Ich weiß bei uns auf der Arbeit
wir haben so ein paar richtige Oldschool Boomer Entwickler die immer Eclipse aufhaben im Fullscreen
und ich bilde mir ein, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher aber ich bilde mir sogar ein ich hab
mal jemand gesehen von denen der hatte einen Webbrowser in Eclipse auf. Da hat es dann
bei mir aufgehört. Da hab ich gedacht was ist denn mit euch los? Welche Virtualisierungssoftware
fände du? Das ist Vmware Workstation. Das hab ich mal vor Jahren gekauft und das war
bei einem Keyshop für irgendwie 8€ oder so und das war eine gute Investition. Ich wechsle
die Bildschirme nicht ich hab mehrere Desktops. Guck da auf dem Desktop ist die Vmware und
hier ist das normale Windows. Achso ja genau Control Alt und File Tasten kannst du hin
und her wechseln. Guck zack zack 1. Desktop 2. Desktop 3. Desktop 3. Desktop 2. Desktop
1. Desktop. Benutzt du auf der Arbeit mittlerweile Windows? Ja und nein ich verwende weiterhin
zum größten Teil Linux aber ich hab auch in Windows allein schon für diese ganzen
Unternehmensanwendungen von Raumbuchung bis Outlook bis Geschiss da brauchst du ab und
zu mal in Windows oder irgendwelche offiziellen PDFs die du nur gescheit mit Windows ausfüllen
kannst. Hast du UV? Was? Weiß ich nicht was das ist. Also ich hab Mac mal virtualisiert
unter VirtualBox. Das lief aber es gab halt keine gescheite GPU Virtualisierung und dementsprechend
lief es langsam. Das da das ist ein Terminal. Was nicht so eklig ist wie das Windows Terminal.
Mittlerweile kann man aber auch wenn man will das offizielle neue Microsoft Terminal verwenden.
Tut auch. Das ist Half Life. Genau. Unreleased ist Half Life Addon hab ich nur ich auf dem
Rechner. Ein Bylist. Ok das kann ich verstehen ja. Gerade bei Embedded Zeug bewegt sich die
Zeit geht langsamer. So also auf gehts. Was? Hat das wirklich expired?
Weil hier gibt es doch regelmäßig Updates. Ja gut so also gehen wir jetzt mal hier in
die Lidlungs VM, clearen den ganzen Clampel und machen mal Go Land auf. Also mein Plan
was ich machen will. Do not import Settings. Nein nein wir brauchen keine Settings. Bin
doch eingeloggt. Was? Ja das ist richtig. Ich hab vor ein paar Tagen mein Account Passwort
geändert. Das ist korrekt. Oh Shit Alter. Ich hab das Passwort nicht hier Moment. Nein
nein das ist ein sinnvolles Passwort. Ich versteh immer noch nicht wie man leicht zwischen
Linux und Windows wechseln kann. Also jetzt jetzt zum Mitschreiben für dich. Also du
klickst hier unten drauf und du machst dir noch einen zweiten Desktop. Du machst dir
noch einen weiteren Desktop. Dann gehst du auf diesen zweiten Desktop und dann startest
du dort vor allem bei Workstation und installierst dir ein Linux drinnen. Und dann kannst du
die Desktop wechseln mit CTRL, Windows Taste, FILE Taste nach links und CTRL, Windows und
FILE Taste nach rechts. So jetzt hab ich ein Problem. Ich muss mein Passwort resetten Leute.
Das ist ja abfuck. Ok. JetBrains. Wartet mal. Ich muss das mal kurz ausmachen. Ich muss
kurz mein Passwort resetzen. Meinung zu Code with me hab ich noch nicht ausprobiert. Es
ist CTRL, Windows, FILE Taste. Also Account. So forgot password. Ja ich hab mein Passwort
vergessen. Jaja. Forgot your password. So Passwort reset. Ok jetzt krieg ich ne Mail
für Passwort reset. So. Reset your JetBrains Account. Jawoll. Copylinked. So Leute das
dauert jetzt kurz ne Minute bis ich mein Passwort reset. So. Neues Passwort. Ok ich
denk mir jetzt mal eins aus kurz. Ne irgendwas was ich schreiben kann weil ich wills nicht
copy pasten. Das Passwort wird enthalten kappa. Ne verrate ich nicht. Ok. Passwort ist strong
sagt JetBrains alles klar. Wenn es ein stronges Passwort ist. Fock. Your Passwort has changed
successfully. Na dann log ich mich mal wieder ein. Da mach ich euch mal aus. Ihr dürft
jetzt nicht zugucken. Weil ich will mich nicht irgendwie Mist eintippen. Und mich nicht vertippen
und ihr sehts dann. So. Kappa. Kappa. Kappa. Kappa. Kappa. Kappa. Kappa. Kappa. Kappa.
So ich bin eingeloggt. Authorization is successful. Das geht nicht. Was ist denn das für ne Scheiße.
You can close this page. Hab ich. Ging nicht. Meine Güte ey. Was ist das für ein Scheiß.
Geht das nicht. Exit. Jetzt muss sich GoLand sogar schließen. Muss ich das jetzt noch
mal machen oder wie. Ok noch mal. So jetzt hat es funktioniert. Ok. So. Jetzt hat es
funktioniert. Subscription Active. Ok. Ich kann euch wieder einschalten.
Alles klar. So. Auf gehts. Wir können anfangen. Sollte jetzt funktionieren. Ok. Nice. Login
hat funktioniert. Also. Neues Projekt. Da gehts schon los. Hab ich überhaupt. Hab ich
überhaupt aktuelles Go installiert. Heißt es vielleicht einfach nur Go. Pacman minus
Go. Ich hab. Ich hab Go gar nicht installiert. Ok. Vielleicht soll ich erst Go installieren
bevor ich Go. Ach so. Deswegen findet er auch kein Go. Go Path. Also ich kann mich
dunkel dran erinnern. Das hier ist die. Modul Variante. Und das hier ist die Oldschool Go
Path Variante. Ich muss jetzt aber mal canceln. Weil ich muss ja Go erst mal installieren.
Yes. Ist denn Go 2.1.18. Die aktuelle. Ne nicht 2.1.18. 1.1.18. 1.1.18. 4.1.18.
Oh. Ich bin einer meiner. Meiner Version hinten dran. MonkaS. So. Also Go Land. Neues
Projekt. Er hat es auch gefunden. Das ist doch schon mal gut. Was ist denn Depp? Was
ist Go Depp? Ein Dependency Management Tool. Es ist aber. Deprecated. Ach jetzt haben sie
Go Modules verwendet. Ok. Ist ja auch geil. Einfach mal ein 13K GitHub Projekt Deprecated.
Also wir wollen Go. So es heißt nicht Awesome Project. Sondern es heißt Pepo Vetter. Habe
ich mir überlegt. Passiert da noch was? Ach ne das wars schon. Ich weiß es gibt ein
eingebautes Terminat. Aber das sackt. Benutzt lieber ein ordentliches. So. Jetzt gehts schon
los. Ich glaube man muss jetzt eine main.go anlegen. Simple Application ist ein gutes
Beispiel. Main. Alles klar. Ok. So. Go Pass ist empty. Chat ist das. Ist das jetzt gut
oder ist das schlecht? Ist das egal? Font größer. Jaja wir machen gleich. Wir machen
gleich die Schrift größer. Passt? Ok. Also Font. Ok. Was? Was? Font. JetBrains Mono.
Nein nein nein. Hack. Hack 16. Hack. Warum ist das 18? Jetzt sind wir noch ein bisschen
klein oder? Chat ist ok so. Oder komm 20. Ah yes. So ist gut. So ist gut. So erkennt
man was. So. Meine. Ach ja. Go legt da immer ziemlich viel Wert drauf. Dass die so irgendeinen
Default haben. Und ich vermute mal, dass Tabs der Default sind. Weil das verwendet Tabs.
Tabs. Genau also das einzige wo ich mich jetzt an Go so spontan dran erinnern kann. Dass
er was sagen kann. FMT. Genau. Print. Prindeln. Kekl zum Beispiel. Und ich bin mir gar nicht
versichert. Braucht man Semikola? Nein braucht man nicht. Ok. So. Also. Go land. Projects.
Pepo fetter. Go. Was? Go run? Ach nee man muss main.go angeben. Ok funktioniert. Ok.
Gibt das sowas wie go watch run? Nein. Go watch run? Missing watch mode for go commands.
Zusätzliche Sachen will ich nicht installieren. Warum exekutest du das im Terminal? Weil
ich das Terminal in der IDE nicht mag. Ach so du meinst für Debugger. Wozu? Ich muss
nix debuggen. Das funktioniert auch so alles. Mal gucken. Go build. Wie groß ist das binary?
Ja zwei Fenster ist viel besser. Ganz ehrlich ich mag das eingebaute Terminal nicht. Ich
finde mein Terminal viel besser. 1,7 MB. Gut ich meine das ist ein hallo welt. Der C-Programmierer
würde jetzt sagen alles über 400 bytes ist bloated. Go build Punkt. Ah da guckt er wahrscheinlich
ob es main gibt. Kann man sowas machen? Moment Leute. Kann man sowas machen wie go build
minus out build oder so? Ne. Dass man ihm sagt wo er was bilden soll. Go build output.
Ja war richtig. Muss ich vielleicht minus O vorher machen? Ah ok. Ne. Ne ne ne ne. Ich
meine das Output directory nicht wie der Output heißen soll. Output directory meine ich.
Ah man macht den fad vorne dran. Also sag ich jetzt z.B. Build und das ist was ist wenn
ich einfach nur so mache. Rm build. Ah ja. Ach ich muss dann was angeben. Ok wunderbar.
So build. Alles klar funktioniert. Ok verstehe sehr schön.
Entre. Ich glaube nicht. Kann ich nachinstallieren? Gibt es das hier? Was ist denn das? Run Arbitr-
Ach so das ist so was wie guard oder so. Ach verstehe. Der Stream ist deutsch. Ne ne das
passt schon. So also alles klar. Machen wir mal weiter. Also wir wollen ja nicht einfach
nur fmt prindlen keggel ausgeben. Peppofetter wird gelöscht. Build. Alles gut passt. Also
wie würden wir dann das ganze jetzt angehen? Als erstes würde ich vorschlagen wir gucken
mal wie man eine Web Anwendung überhaupt startet. Go lang. Wie heißt das Ding? libhttp? Ne.
Nethttp heißt das. Nethttp. Jetzt ist halt die Frage chat. Da müssen wir fast ne Umfrage
machen. Fiber oder Nethttp? Ich mein ich brauch irgendwie 3 AP Endpunkte. Das sollte eigentlich
mit allem möglich sein. Wieso das hier sieht doch super easy aus. Warum braucht man da
noch mehr? Das sieht doch eigentlich relativ simpel aus. Ja. Wir probieren es jetzt mal
mit dem eingebauten Package. Also wie würde man das jetzt machen? Gibt es eigentlich
für ein vollständiges Sample wie das funktioniert? Wie das ist kein Server? Atttp Handle? Doch.
Ach das ist beides. Ok so. Ne Moment. Ach hier ist ein Minimal Beispiel. Ok. Also blablabla.
Was da muss dann... Moment. Warte mal ne das muss alles in Main rein. So. Atttp Handle.
Wie ist denn die? Kann man das? Ne. Wie schreibt man so was inline? Wie sieht denn das in Go
aus? Die Zeile drunter? Ach hier. Ah. Ach so. Guck mal Funk quasi. Ah verstehe. Ok alles
klar. Also das heißt. Wie gebe ich da jetzt an ob es Get oder Post oder sowas ist? Egal
probieren wir das mal aus. Also pepo go run main. Listen da jetzt? Curl localhost 8080.
Ach ne. Bar. Ja funktioniert. Funst. Seht ihr noch was chat wenn ich das hier unten rechts
so mache? Ja ganz knapp. Ganz knapp sieht man das noch. Ok also jetzt haben wir einen
Web Server. Das ist ja tatsächlich schon mal relativ easy gewesen. Handle func bar. Ok
also. Ich will eine simple Web Seite machen die random essen Sachen mit Bildern anzeigt.
Einfach nur dass ich irgendwas naja sinnvoll ist es nicht aber irgendwas machen kann. Das
heißt wir brauchen jetzt im Prinzip eigentlich nur ein AP Endpunkt. Ach so wie serve ich
denn Static Files überhaupt? Ich muss ja mein HTML irgendwie ausliefern. NET HTTP SERVE STATIC.
SERVING STATIC FILE WITH GO. Ja wo ist das Beispiel? HTTP FILE SERVE. Ok das ist tatsächlich
relativ easy. Wir copy pasten uns unsere Sache zusammen. POG. Also slash static. Ja www root
wir nennen das wenn schon gescheit. Also pepo fetter ordner www root. Oder gibt es irgendeinen
coolen Namen was die krassen Golang Leute verwenden für ihr HTML Zeug. So new HTML
index.html. Das einzige was jetzt da drauf steht im Kickel. Im Titel. Kackel pepo fetter.
Lulw. So das muss jetzt erst mal reichen und gucken ob es funktioniert. Gibt doch extra
go templates. Wie templates? Wat? Ich will statische Webseiten surfen ich will keine
templates. Schaut ihr mal wirklich GOX und GT an. Naja das sind Projekte mit 100.000
Zeilen Source Code was soll ich mir da angucken. Ich kann es mir vorstellen die werden einige
server side rendern. Und dann mit templates. Aber will ich ja nicht ich will ja nicht server
side rendern ich will ja einfach nur statisches HTML ausliefern und dann ein bisschen JavaScript
rein basteln was hier mein Zeug abfragt. Also von der Idee her sollte ich jetzt sollte
ich doch jetzt wenn ich das abfrage mein HTML bekommen. Ja ist doch easy also localhost
port 80 80. Kriegen wir unser HTML sehr schön ist doch alles mehr brauchen wir doch erstmal
gar nicht. So index.html. Nee wir brauchen auf keinen Fall irgendwelche templates.
Nein ich bin Wubblos. Eindeutig wir haben bloß zufällig den gleichen Avatar und wir
hören uns nur zufällig genau gleich an aber ansonsten gibt es keine weiteren und wir können
auch beide die Bahn nicht leiden. Aber ansonsten gibt es keine weiteren Überschneidungen.
Vorgestern habe ich ein bisschen übertrieben glaube ich. Gestern war ich ein bisschen.
Das ist wahrscheinlich schon wieder Content den man auf Twitch nicht zeigen darf. Gestern
habe ich schon ein bisschen übertrieben. Gestern habe ich ein bisschen übertrieben.
Es ging aber schon wieder gut los. Zug ist angeblich laut der App da und Zug ist laut
der App schon abgefahren aber Zug war noch nicht in Sichtweite. Und ich habe 10 Minuten
rum gestanden das Ding kam 10 Minuten zu spät angeblich war der Zug schon 2 Stationen weiter.
Ja also es ist echt dieser Laden das ist so das sind solche abgefuckten Pisser alter
das kann man nicht anders sagen. Ich hasse die Bahn das ist unglaublich. Es gibt nichts
das ich so sehr hasse wie die Bahn. Ja es gibt Leute mit denen verstehe ich mich nicht.
Es gibt Leute mit denen kann ich auch überhaupt nicht leiden. Aber so richtigen Hass habe
ich eigentlich nur gegen die Bahn gegen sonst nichts. Und wisst ihr was das lustige ist
Leute wenn ich auf Twitter lese wenn Leute mit der Bahn fahren die haben alle immer die
gleichen Probleme. Und dann machen die auch noch Werbung so nach dem Motto ja in Urlaub
fahre ich mit der Bahn entspannt und günstig ankommen. Es ist weder günstig noch ist es
entspannt. Mit dem 9 Euro Ticket ist es günstig ja. Aber du kannst kein ICE fahren da kommst
es rechnet an. So wird das nichts mit einer DevOps Engineer Stelle bei der DB das ist richtig
ich habe ja auch gesagt ich auch wenn die Stellen von der Bahn noch so gut passen ich
bewerbe mich nicht bei der Bahn. Übrigens es gibt ein Ruby Projekt auf GitHub was so
heißt wie du um Software zu deployen heißt genau so. Mit was wechselst du zwischen Windows
und Linux. Das beides sind nicht beides VMs es ist nur Linux eine VM. Windows ist der
Host. Ich wechsle über die in Windows eingebaute Multiple Desktop Funktion. Du kannst unter
Windows mehrere Desktops haben und ich drücke einfach Control Windows Feiltaste rechts komme
ich auf den Linux Desktop nochmal Feiltaste rechts komme ich auf den freien Desktop und
Feiltaste links wieder zurück. Es ist nur es ist nur VMWare guck so erkennt man es
glaube ich besser hier ist Windows hier ist VMWare hier ist leerer Desktop. So also weiter
weiter im leer ja das wird nicht von VM ach so doch du hast recht ich habe dir ich habe
was vergessen zu erwähnen ja normalerweise du hast recht ich drückte schon so automatisch
ich denke da nicht dran. Wenn ich in der VM Control Windows drücke dann geht es in die
VM. Du musst vorher Control Alt drücken guck mal Control Alt da siehst du ja eurer Mauszeiger
guck ich drück Control Alt das ist das Escape der Standard Escape Sequenz die Standard Escape
Sequenz für VMWare Control Alt dann lässt VMWare den Fokus macht den Fokus raus von
Tastatur und dann drückst du Control Windows links rechts also sprich ich drücke eigentlich
relativ schnell beides hintereinander ich habe das mir schon so angewöhnt ja also ich
drück Control Alt Control Windows Feiltaste aber das liegt halt direkt nebeneinander deswegen
ist das nicht so und nicht schwierig du könntest wahrscheinlich VMWare den Escape Button umstellen
auf Control Windows das funktioniert vielleicht ne zurück in die VM ist einfach zurück in
die VM einfach reinklicken ja genau das ist aber eine gute Frage kann man diesen Escape
diese Escape Sequenz umstellen hier hotkey provide a shortcut probieren wir mal vielleicht
brauche ich das gar nicht mehr guck mal stellen wir mal um auf Control Windows ne das geht
nicht das funktioniert nicht weil du musst du musst loslassen dass das das ist das frisst
also ich kann jetzt Control Windows Control Windows drücken aber dann bleibe ich lieber
bei dem woran ich mich gewöhnt habe wenn es bei bei Keydown wäre das wäre natürlich
cool weil dann wird es gleich rausspringen naja aber die Hand an der Tastatur lässt
er doch eh nicht weil du zu 90 prozent wenn du nicht gerade da am basteln bist mit der
Maus im Browser bist ach so wobei du hast nicht unrecht wenn man Feiltaste drückt benutzt
man ja eh meistens die rechte Hand ja hast recht hast recht da muss man nicht ja du ist
wahrscheinlich gar nicht so schlecht ja hey das ist gut Chat High IQ Chat wieder hier
Massive Massive Brain das finde ich gar nicht schlecht guck mal man würde jetzt einfach
sagen Control Windows rechts und dann drücke ich einfach Control G und bin wieder in der
VM das ist cool das finde ich ok das muss da muss ich mich dran gewöhnen das ist gut
das ist praktischer als zwischen Feiltaste und Maus hin und her zu greifen Desktop bester
Desktop very clean
das wollte ich jetzt noch gerade sagen zu dem Thema vorher Control G für die für die
Ach ja was anderes ich hatte mal ein Makro für die Maus das der erkannt hat wenn du
in VMWare bist dass dann dass ich mir ich konnte mit der Maustaste umschalten ich hatte
mir ein Makro gebaut in dieser Logitech Software wenn er erkannt hat dass ich in VMWare bin
konnte ich Maustaste drücken also die Seitentasten und konnte zwischen Desktop hin und her schicken
weil Maus Makros gehen ja von der Maus aus Low Level die kann Windows und VMWare nicht
abfangen und da hatte ich dann quasi eine Maus Makro eingebaut das ist für mich schon
gut Control Alt drückt und den Switch macht aber ja benutze ich nicht mehr ist auch egal
jetzt müssen wir mal hier langsam ein bisschen Pepofat API also wir haben einen File Server
der statisches HTML ausliefern kann so und so registriert man sich Get Funktionen oder
wie würde ich denn daraus jetzt ein Post machen was ist denn wenn ich da jetzt sage ich will
ein Post machen ist das dann auch da drin da drin ach das ist beides registriert für Post
und Get ach so man registriert das hier nicht mit Get sondern man müsste dann quasi selbst
die Abfrage machen ob es Get oder Post ist also sprich selbst wenn ich sowas abgedrehtes
mache wie Delete oder oder Patch oder so dann ist das ok ah dann müsste ich die das ist
das ist erstmal ein bisschen gewöhnungsbedürftig aber gibt schlimmeres
warum kann ich hier eigentlich ein Händler angeben für was ist denn der Händler hier
gut gibt es irgendwie Hilfe wenn man das auf Händler weißte nicht was es gibt es da irgendwie
eine Hilfe was was ist ist das so Default Händler für alles oder oder so oder ist das
wenn ich irgendwie eine Routing Library oder so registrieren will ja ja ok dann vielleicht
also wenn ich selbst handeln will wohin was geht bevor es in die eigentlichen Funktionen
reingeht wir haben mal einen HTTP Server für einen ESP32 selbst gebaut so einen ganz ganz
minimalistischen der nur Get konnte und nicht viel ok also jetzt lasst mal überlegen Leute
Big Brain Time also das ist ja schon mal Blödsinn was da steht das brauchen wir nicht also
statische Sachen ausliefern alles gut www root ist unser Index drinne so also wir brauchen
wahrscheinlich einen Endpunkt und jetzt müssen wir erstmal uns gucken wie man in der SQLite
Datenbank macht also wir brauchen einen Endpunkt und der heißt einfach nur Food Random Food
und da gibt es eine JSON Response wie macht man eine JSON Response ok jetzt wird es jetzt
wird es advanceder also Writer write byte Moment fnt wait a minute was machen die da
überhaupt f print a das ist quasi was um in streams oder so reinzuschreiben anscheinend
vermute ich mal ok also jays wie wie macht man ich muss mir jetzt im Tutorial angucken
go lang jason wie funktioniert das ok da habt ihr recht den header den header können wir
schon mal setzen header dann was write set set ok Content Type muss man ist das eigentlich
Pflicht dass man das groß und klein schreibt oder geht das auch so müssen wir mal in Standard
gucken application jason so also ich habe ja noch nicht neu gestartet starten wir mal
neu gucken wir mal ob der den header ordentlich setzt ich gebe dir header alter lahm so one
on one rust quickscope only was not found a food heißt es jetzt ja header application
jason ok passt das ist richtig so alles gut ok Content Type so jason wie geht das go lang
jason complete guide to jason in golang with examples alles klar wow das ist ja five head
so was wie dynamic gibt es da nicht
decoding jason into structs nested objects primitive types
maps boah nee das will ich nicht machen das ist eklig dass das will ich tatsächlich nicht
machen nee also das heißt von der Idee her brauche ich jetzt ein Typ der so aussieht wie
das was ich was ich zurück liefern will also sowas sowas hier oder also sprich ich bräuchte
an sowas hier type ich food string name description ja ist ok description image image url so so
in der richtung würde ich sagen so und
wie kriege ich punkt nee nee ma was marshal hier so was jason bird type ok das wird mal
ausprobieren mal ausprobieren also ich lege jetzt erstmal ein eine food an so ein food
was nicht geht unused variable ja ich weiß ich habe es ja nur in den zwei eingesetzt
also machen wir was testen name kacke description 0w größer kacke w image url is loop.png ist
vollkommen wurscht muss da abschließendes komma hin aha so pepo fett nee moment das
mache ich mal mal gucken ob ich das jetzt auf die reihe kriege also jason wahrscheinlich
die coder encoder also nee das ist falsch das ist falsch marshal so im moment das ist
ja auch und wie geht das jetzt data data so das hier ist der fehler code gehe ich mal
von aus wenn ich mich richtig entsinne also das hier ist der error der mich nicht interessiert
weil ich einfach von ausgehen dass es funktioniert so und wie kriege ich jetzt den data das data
zurück anscheinend anscheinend so fmt f printf kann ich kann ich da einfach jetzt so nee
moment nee nee das muss doch anders gehen das muss doch irgendwie gehen mit w right
oder sowas so das geht woher weiß ich dass das geht ich habe einfach geraten aber jetzt
ok alles klar easy easy so jetzt nur mal hoffen dass es jetzt auch funktioniert hey funktioniert
guck mal lv größer kacke wie image url ok das ist tatsächlich relativ nett zu benutzen
das ist doch ist doch ganz ok gibt es nichts wo ich mich jetzt also bis jetzt nichts wo
ich mich beschweren können was hat er hierfür schmerzen unhandled error handle error wie
unused variable das ist was returnt das ding überhaupt ach wie viel er geschrieben hatte
das ist mir egal kann man das auch ignore kann ich das auch ignore indem ich irgendwie sowas
mache oder so nee oder go ignore return ach man muss jedes element doppelt angeben oder
was also quasi was ist jetzt der unterschied
was ist denn jetzt da der unterschied also das hier nee aber sowas hier geht nicht oder
einfach alles ignorieren naja anscheinend aber das sieht das sieht schon ziemlich ziemlich
kacke aus oder müsst ihr zugeben also ist das hier normale also macht man das in go
so also ist das so sieht man das häufig in go code wenn du alles ignorieren will stimmt
da kann ich einfach weglassen oder der sagte mir halt hier unhandled error aber solang der
beim kompilieren nicht rum merkt hat ist ja alles ok wie soll wie soll ich auf diesen
error reagieren leute meine reaktion auf diesen error war ich brech den request ab was wahrscheinlich
aber auch bei einem error vorkommt also mir fällt nicht ein wie ich auf diesen error
sinnvoll reagieren sollte ok aber ich muss sagen so vom handling her so bis jetzt ist
das doch alles ganz in ordnung ach ja wie ist und wie macht man überhaupt die schreibweise
in go schreibt man den graben überhaupt so an feldern von structs oder schreibt man
image url wie schreibt man das jetzt eigentlich so also hier also kein kebab case und kein
snake case und sonst was sondern im prinzip so paschal case wie das sich haben auch mag
image url wäre convention ja warum warum ist das convention also warum url alles groß
ach so ja wenn ihr das sagt dann machen wir das so ja also übrigens kippen was mit kebab
case gemeint das ist so dass wir die leute das in java skript machen irgendwie so also
ich data huge chat so das wäre das wäre kebab case warum ist das kebab case ein weil
das so ein spieß ist weil das bisschen aussieht wie so ein döner so ein döner spieß ich
habe mir das nicht ausgedacht ok also so funktioniert jetzt wissen wir schon mal bescheid so würden
wir ein objekt da serialisieren gut jetzt damit wir überhaupt ein bisschen ein bisschen
fronterzeug machen können müssen wir irgendwie eine sqlite datenbank füllen mit put und dazu
habe ich schon mal was im vorfeld gesucht aber bevor ich euch das zeige was verwendet
man in go als fake datengenerator ich habe vorhin hier mal gesucht da gibt es ja auch
wieder tausend solcher listen und diese liste hat nur 84.000 sterne da habe ich mal nach
faker gesucht und habe festgestellt die faker libraries die faker heißen in go sind doof
aber es gibt eine gute library die fake it oder so hieß und die macht einen ganz guten
eindruck was verwendet ihr zum fake daten generieren go fake it ok also das das dann
taugt das also ich verwende bei dort net meistens das das ist ziemlich hoge ok go fake it ist
beste das ist schön dass ihr das auch so sieht weil go fake it hat das ist für mich sehr
praktisch dinner sie fall voll fand dinner gut mit nn ja dinner da kann man sich random
essen generieren lassen was natürlich für unsere random food seite sinnvoll ist ja und
jetzt stehe ich auf dem schlauch leute wie kriege ich das hinzugefügt zu meinem projekt
nicht verraten ich komme da selbst drauf ach so einfach import keckel ok das ist ja easy
so
Ah und Sync Dependency auf Pepo Feta.
Was ist das jetzt?
Ok das scheint funktioniert zu haben, gut, ok, alles klar, ok, also, Faker, gabs immer
Lollspieler da so hieß, so, Name, Food, Minecraft, Food, ja gut, warum nicht, ja, Food, ok,
ah so, nee, einfach Dinner, ok, also, füllen wirs mal neu aus, Garlic Herb, was, Garlic
Herb, Roasted Red Skin Potatoes, alles klar, nächstes, TGE Fridays Mutslide, was auch
immer das ist, Spinach Salad with Feta Cheese, Asian Broccoli Salad, Brr Broccoli, Alter,
Heusin, Heusin, ah das ist irgendwas Chinesisches oder, Heusin Marinated Wing Pieces, Chicken
Wings quasi, Sweet and Sour Pork Balls, alles klar, ok, Random Essen Generator funktioniert
schon, was kann der denn sonst noch alles generieren, hier warte mal, Dinner, was hat
denn da sonst was, Snack, Dessert, Fruit, was macht der denn sonst noch alles, Minecraft
Food, ich generiere mal kurz Minecraft Food, ich will wissen was da, ich will einfach nur
wissen was er da generiert hat, was kommt denn da raus, Golden Carrot, Honey Bottle,
Sweetberry ok, das ist anscheinend das was es in Minecraft gibt zu, für Peppofett, ok
mit Description gibt es sowas wie Lorem, ja beste, Lorem Ipsum, Word Count 20, wir brauchen
irgendwas auf der Webseite zum Anzeigen, ok wunderbar, perfekt, also wir haben Crock
Pot Caramelized Onion Pot Roast und das ist dann die Beschreibung, das ist die Image
wohl, ok das passt eigentlich ganz gut, wie mache ich das jetzt mit dem Bild, ne Moment,
bevor ich das mit dem Bild mache, wie kriege ich das jetzt, wie kriege ich das alles in
der SQLite Datenbank, ok also wie ist das Ding, GORM was der Chat vorhin erzählt hat,
GORM, Fantastic ORM Library for Golang, ok ich mag das, dass die sich selbst schon mal
geil finden, das ist schon mal gut, Examples SQLite, SQLite Connecting to Database, GORM
is PainzChamp, ok was ist besser oder warum, ich hab da keine Ahnung von SQLite, ok also
GORM, my old driver SQLite, ach hier, ach hier, ach hier, ok, Raw SQL, ne blieb
im Leben nicht, warum soll ich Raw SQL, ne ne, ok also, hat Golang sowas wie Package
Suche, ne, null, gibt's nicht, GORM, so und was muss man jetzt machen, nochmal Sync, Sync
Dependencies, alles klar, DB Error, Error, Kackel, wer hat schon Errors, Open SQLite,
also gut DB, Error ist richtig bloated, ja, kann ich jetzt, ok ich mach mal irgendein Query,
was es ja nicht gibt, ne, ok da geht's schon los, Sekunde wie frag ich da jetzt was ab
raus, weil sowas wie DB-Kontext ist wahrscheinlich nicht, ne, Feind, Eier, Feind, hör, ok,
Feind, First, ok Feind aber ich hab keine Ahnung wie ich Feind verwende, Feind und User,
der hat doch User hier nirgendswo angelegt, oder, äh was ist denn User in dem Fall, ja
oder ist User der Typ, also müsste ich jetzt quasi sowas hier sagen, ähm, also quasi
gut, ne, ich hab keine Ahnung wie das funktioniert, Feind, gut, was, what the, was das, was ist
das, was, was soll denn das jetzt sein, legt er jetzt ein leeres Struct an oder wie, aber
ok das check ich nicht, was, was, ne das Ergebnis kommt doch als, kommt doch hier als, ähm,
irgendwie Result oder, achso, der schreibt das da rein, achso, ok das ist, ok das ist
irgendwie umständlich, das ist doch bestimmt nur weil Go keine Generics konnte bis jetzt
oder, also sprich ich müsste jetzt quasi, äh sowas hier an den Result gleich gut sowas
hier, ach und da schreibt er das jetzt rein, ok verstehe, aber gut, ich hab in meiner SQLite
die Datenbank nix drinstehen, aber soweit ja ok, wie, connection refused, äh warum ist
das nicht als hätt ich irgendwas kaputt gemacht oder so großartig, ok, wait a minute der hat
einfach so lange gebraucht jetzt die Datenbank zu erstellen oder was, hat der grad wirklich
irgendwie 10 Sekunden meine Datenbank erstellt, ah Schein, wie groß ist denn die jetzt, die
müsste ja leer sein, Null, Utb, Null, ok alles klar, ich glaube ich hab's verstanden,
das heißt, so das heißt wir füllen jetzt erstmal die Datenbank mit random food, zumindest
mal zum ausprobieren, gut, das heißt ich kommentiere mal diesen ganzen Krempel hier
unten aus, äh tja, ich weiß jetzt nicht der Shortcut da drinne für auskommentieren, ok
oh go, Vorschleife, Pifad, range, ne Moment, wie ging das nochmal, oh x, ne, range, ohje,
1 zu 5, ne, ahja, x gleich range, range, ok, range und jetzt so, ne ok, go for loop da
muss ich nachgucken, keine Ahnung, 5 basic, 5 basic go pattern, ach man kann auch ne stinknormale
Schleife machen, while loop, Moment eine while loop die mit 4 anfängt, krasse while loop,
nisch, ich will einfach ne Schleife haben, die von 1 bis 100 läuft, das heißt ich mach
einfach sowas hier oder, also ich mach doch einfach sowas, also irgendwie 100 Gerichte,
so und jetzt sag ich db create, so und jetzt muss ich wahrscheinlich, ich vermute mal,
by the way kann mir irgendjemand schlüssig erklären warum man auch mit var variablen
anlegen kann in go, ich kann jetzt ja auch sowas machen wie food gleich food, ja das
funktioniert ja auch, aber ich hab keine Ahnung warum ist das überhaupt, also warum geht das,
sowas würde niemand schreiben, ja das denke ich mir aber warum gibt es das, gut, was das
ist wenn man nicht selber initialisieren will, also ist in das hier quasi was, ohne dass
ich davor geschrieben hab oder, stimmt wie würde man eigentlich default values geben,
geht das überhaupt, kann man default values geben, wieso, so, so, nee oder, go struct
default value, what, das ist ein constructor oder sowas, gell, so eine art constructor
ist das, ok, naja dann halt keine default values, ja aber jetzt mal dumme Frage, wenn das keine
default values gibt, auf was steht das denn hier denn, ist das dann ein null pointer oder
auf was steht das, wenn ich das struct anlegen kann ohne zu initialisieren, auf irgendwas
muss es ja stehen, in C ist es relativ einfach, es ist undefined, ist das irgendwas, was da
halt mal vorher stand, auf den default value des types, ahja, das heißt jeder type muss
ein default value haben, so ok jetzt kriegen wir 100 foods, Leute ich muss mal ganz schnell
was zu trinken holen, ich bin gleich wieder da.
Wieder hier, oder auch nicht, da, da, jetzt, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
ok, also weiter, so würde man 100, 100 random foods anlegen, wobei da ja nichts drin steht,
das heißt hier müsste ich jetzt eigentlich das da machen
okay alles klar verstehe verstehe gibt es nicht irgendwie eine gut moment
da gibt es auch free free api free api wir suchen jetzt einfach eine api mit mit
food bildern
achtung momento musst db auto migrate benutzen damit er eine tabelle für den
typ erstellt es stand hier irgendwo drin das habe ich eben gerade gesehen
migrate hier ah sqlite muss ich das muss ich anscheinend ok also sprich gut aber
dieses wir legen in leeres truck dann oder so ist schon irgendwie ein bisschen
pepega also so muss man das machen ok er aus er aus werden natürlich prinzipiell
prinzipiell ignored bei mir aber kann er euch kann er euch anzeigen also das
blub blub blub also gibt es gibt es eine food image api oder so was bacon mock
ab was nicht alles gibt random pictures of koffe also wir brauchen irgendwas
ohne ohne authentifizierung random pictures of koffe klar udish rennen
picture of dishes das ist genau so was brauche ich moment es gibt es aber gar
nicht ja doch so was so was so was top random
random futter
random
meine das sind nur 572 drinnen ok was haben wir sonst noch
ich kann auch mal nach mieten nach meal oder dinner oder so suchen
gibt keine projektbeschreibung heute ich übe ein bisschen go und wir machen
eine webseite die random essen anzeigt die webseite als treffen pepo fetter so
was haben wir sonst noch hier fruit weil der supermarkt data food products
database
das ist die gesamte datenbank oder was
ich es gibt es auch als xml ja da habe ich ja drauf gewartet techo fancy
skihunter jetzt was mit meal vielleicht meal db das klingt doch schon mal nicht
verkehrt meal db ich brauche eigentlich nur bilder von essen sonst nix random
hier look up a single random meal
es gibt sogar ein youtube bild youtube video wie das zubereitet wird image
ja das ist doch ganz ok da wir ziehen uns einfach von dort ein image da können
wir auch gleich lernen wie man gleich lernen wie man hatte tp request macht
und dann müssen wir ok jetzt ist natürlich die frage machen wir es
schön oder machen wir es einfach also sprich speichern wir die bilder in der
sq light datenbank oder speichern wir die bilder im filesystem und schreiben in
die sq light datenbank plus ein name rein ich würde sagen wir schreiben plus
den name in die sq light datenbank rein oder chat was sagt ihr ich
ich bei ich speichere nur den fad ja ok also wir haben jetzt ein random
generator für essen namen und irgendwie random text ok jetzt ist die große
preisfrage wie mache ich ein get requests in go also wahrscheinlich ht tp
ht tp get wie einfach so das wäre aber ganz schön easy
ist halt so wäre das ist das nee das ist das alles
jetzt war fmt prindlen ist halt nee nee das wird so einfach
ach so er war lul er war teckel alter wer interessiert er aus
access control
was
ach nee das sind die heller ich brauch so was wie body oder sowas ach guck mal
hier body gut ok ja ja ich verstehe oder ok da muss ich jetzt mal gut da muss
ich google das war ich nicht go ht tp get so ht tp get response ht tp response
was ok da wäre ich im leben nicht drauf gekommen das das hätte ich nicht
gecheckt ok dann ich nenne ich sp error
warte mal wo kommt jetzt der body her
das legt er hier an der mecker dass ich nicht verwende
so kann ich kann ich jetzt ausgeben warte warte ich auch read string oder so vielleicht
hier ne ne so einfach ist es nicht
was einfach carsten oder was so
woher weiß ich wann ich was carsten muss und wann nicht das ist ich weiß nicht das
ist irgendwie erstes und nicht so weiß ich nicht so klar irgendwie im handling
gibt es gibt es warum gibt es denn kein read string oder sowas ich meine das ist doch was
man 99 prozent der zeit verwenden will ok also ich habe noch mal andere idee also
sprich wir müssten das jetzt ja deserialisieren das jason was da
zurückkommt so in welchem format kommt denn das jason da zurück random ist da
nur mit carsten los jetzt frage ich mich auch vor dem habe ich ewig nichts mehr gehört
also ich meine ich kenne das das video ja aber ich frage mich was der master
kreiber so treibt
moment man kriegt ein array zurück mit nur einem element das ist ja schon mal
hardcore ppega wie ok ok also das heißt ich bräuchte jetzt noch einen neuen type
das nenne ich dann mal irgendwie keine ahnung meal ap response oder so so und
das ding hat eine image
trümmel sam hat das trümmel am string
so und das heißt ich kann das lesen dann mit ok moment jetzt jetzt muss ich mal
gucken wie würde man das jetzt korrekt machen man sagt jetzt jason
de ne ne was ist das gegenteil von marschall ent marschall an marschall an
marschall ok alles klar ok body so
und dann zu das muss ich mir das muss ich mir in dem in der anleitung noch mal
angucken wie das wie das funktioniert hat ja noch irgendwie sondern
die code sneakers
und meist dort variable also quasi
e
Mir also quasi sowas hier oder was nur mal nur mal testweise so
Moment und hier will er aber nicht body haben sondern er will er will was was will er denn
haben beider also quasi das da jetzt sehe ich das richtig ja ist das so ne
ach so ja das gibt ja noch ein error code so was das ist ja das ist ja eklig
also sprich müsste ich irgendwie das muss auf jeden fall eine eigene funktion machen
dass ist das ist zu viel auf einmal gut body close kann ich mir wahrscheinlich sparen read
all kann ich mir auch sparen aber das ist doch insofern ist es doch komplett in ordnung
wäre das doch komplett in ordnung also also hier keine ahnung bei jetzt so jetzt jetzt ist
so was ist denn jetzt schon wieder das problem ach so weil ich den error code vergessen habe
ok ok ich glaube mit go werde ich nicht so richtig warm so keckels aber mit einem und
was was macht er denn wenn ich es ohne und mache das probieren wir jetzt mal aus so an marsch
links und hier steht jetzt das result drinne oder wie also hier kann ich mir jetzt quasi
ausgeben lassen ok das funktioniert nicht das funktioniert nicht ok warum
kennst du nicht mit java gut aus nein irgendjemand klopft die warum das jetzt nicht funktioniert
also ich habe keine ahnung das gibt einen array zurück du hast recht du hast recht das
gibt einen array zurück also eigentlich will ich das ist ja eklig das heißt eigentlich
will ich sowas haben wie
sowas irgendwie so jetzt ein array ok feifert array syntax moment nicht verraten chat mil
ap item so result ne ach du scheiße man wie ist die richtige sonntags type from jason
sehr gute idee sehr gute idee das ist das tatsächlich gute idee das machen wir so pass
mal auf pass passt mal auf beim generate go type from jason yes easy easy aber das will
ich ja alles gar nicht haben type t struck moment was zum was macht er da alles moment
wo ist wo ist mein image das will ich ja alles gar nicht ich will einfach nur einfach nur
das image das thumbnail haben ok das ist das ist jetzt für mich zu high IQ wie was macht
das ding da überhaupt was ist das was ich hier sehe type t struck meals dings ist das
irgendwie so nested nested typ definition oder sowas aber richtig lost ja oder ist das
irgendwie generic oder was ist was ist das was sagt uns das t an der stelle t ist quasi
so der root type oder monkaS also so müsste ich das nee achso das habe ich schon mal achso
alles klar jetzt bin das jetzt funktioniert ob das tut ich habe da so meine zweifel ok
also null nee ach nee moment nicht so hier meals null so jetzt bin ich immer gespannt
ob das klappt ey hey easy ok wenn man weiß wie es geht dann ist das durchaus durchaus
brauchbar es ist durchaus das ist ok das ist ok ok also sag ich nicht wie ich kann
fetsch fetsch ach ja go schreibweise so oder oder oder so wie macht man functions fetsch
im images so wunderbar so ok ja dann kopieren wir das hier mal rein so das da wie macht
man return werte wir sind wahrscheinlich nicht in rust also ist es wahrscheinlich ist es
nicht ist es nicht sowas sondern es einfach nur wahrscheinlich so eigentlich einfach
nur so error handling keckel braucht man nicht ok also ja hat das hat das auto vorschläge
für variablen nee doch gut naja eigentlich was fürs api respawn ja tja wie nennt man
das jetzt eigentlich wie könnte man das nennen so api respawn ja response haben wir ja schon
hier deswegen passt das irgendwie nicht so ist in ordnung kann man mit so kann man das
jetzt noch irgendwie schöner schreiben also sprich braucht man braucht man diese dinger
braucht man diese drei oder gibt es irgendwie eine abkürzung in in was weiß ich so in in
dieser form oder so wahrscheinlich nicht jetzt echt größter struggle wie man das benennt
moment hier würde man aber war api root mit was
also nur dass ich das jetzt richtig verstehe das war mir im vorfeld auch schon klar also
es gibt gleich es gibt doppelpunkt gleich und es gibt wahr doppelpunkt gleich ist variablen
anlegen und gleich was reinschreiben gleich ist wenn es die variablen schon gibt was reinschreiben
und wahr ist alles mit null initialisiert anlegen braucht man da drei verschiedene sachen warum
nicht immer so ich mein warum gibt es was ist eigentlich die daseinsberechtigung davon
warum nicht einfach sowas das könnte man direkt lesen das geht doch bestimmt auch oder
ja das geht doch genauso kürzer naja aber das ist doch also wenn man doch sowas einführt
aber nachdem das auch geht na das da kann man sich jetzt aber echt drüber streiten
aber ok mein go stellt einetwegen so ich glaube das kann man eigentlich alles untereinander
schreiben alles klar so jetzt kriegen wir hier die adresse für das bild das ist drin
weil es sonst keine streitpunkte gebe ja das muss man sagen gewisserweise hat es ja schon
was wahres was wahres dran an dem was du sagst ich mein die haben standardmäßig drinne
wieder text formatiert wird die entstanden standardmäßig drinne wie die einrückung
sein muss die am standard mich drinnen in welcher reinfolge die import sein müssen
und sowas das ist schon recht einheitlich das hat auch seine vorteile ja ok so und jetzt
müssen wir den kram speichern wir brauchen mal ein bild bild wir brauchen ordner für
bilder images moment aber nicht aber nicht dort sondern unterhalb von ww root images
ok und jetzt muss ich das downloaden also sprich das hier also sprich mir ok ok ok das heißt
wir machen noch mal wir sagen noch mal get allerdings jetzt getten wir das da ne moment
schwarze schwarze das da getten wir das getten wir massive get ja das müssen wir den kram
wirklich anders sehen denn ap res res dann ist das hier kanon image res punkt gleich
so und jetzt ok jetzt kommt der nächste jetzt wie würde ich das in einem feil speichern
also ich würde mal vermuten man macht i o reads body und dann macht man sowas wie feil
ne feil fs fs feil klingt gut ne aber es könnte durchaus ein read read string geben
fs feil ne fs feil read ok golang fs feil was anders macht golang write files writing
files os write file ok der chat sagt i o util write file oder os feil warum gibt es da zwei
verschiedene varianten i o util ach das kümmert sich auch ums closen ok write file ok also
heißt im endeffekt ich will nach punkt slash ww root images so und jetzt braucht jetzt
braucht das image irgendein irgendeine gut oder so golang gut was haben wir da gibt
es aber etwas eingebautes i o utils ist nicht so gerne gesehen weil warum nicht
warum ist es nicht gerne gesehen macht auch einen sinnvollen eindruck aber bei random reicht
ja auch random wobei ja s of go ok moment s of go 1.16 ok das ist noch nicht so alt
same functionality is now provided by package i o or package os ok also also os write file
oder wie oder i o write file naja gut macht ja macht ja keinen wirklichen unterschied da
nehmen wir halt nehmen wir halt os os write files ok normalerweise was anderes wie sah
hier noch mal die response von aus nil api das ist auch schon unic hintendran oder da
müssen wir auch doch wir machen das generate gut go muss man kurz klima anmachen viel zu
arm hier haben wir denn kenne ich nicht aber 27 grad oder so ok google good ops was jetzt
zink nicht sort alter zink zink id new ja ok alles klar ich hoffe dass er passt irgendwie
ist irgendwie sinnig was man was wir jetzt hier machen all die so und jetzt sagen wir
os os und wie war das right feil ok also das heißt wir brauchen so was hier plus wie sind
template strings in in go gibt es da so was sowas in der richtung gibt es gibt es da so
was go lang template strings was die oder das denen meint es das muss irgendwie einfachere
einfacher gehen
ja sowas genau moment moment nur durch dass es richtig verstehe string formatierung ist
in go noch schlimmer als in c++ kann doch gar nicht sein es kann eigentlich nix schlimmer
sein als in c++ gut in c++ ist es auch nur nicht so schlimm weil die sich das von python
abgeguckt haben muss man das wirklich so machen ich meine ich könnte doch bestimmt auch so
machen oder das geht auch nicht und was will er was will er sonst noch haben data ich bin
verwirrt sekunde warte mal image image response ja das ist das ist doof dass man das nicht
inline schreiben kann jetzt müsste ich jetzt bräuchte ich zweimal bites ja jetzt bräuchte
ich zweimal müsste ich jetzt bräuchte ich zweimal so und einmal so das ist doch bestimmt
verpönt in go oder sowas doppelt zu benutzen an variablen
ist es jetzt ein string string so ok so bei jetzt
und was will er jetzt was hat er jetzt noch für schmerzen permission file mode will er
was will er da haben unix permissions oder so also irgendwie sowas was ich 600 oder oder
so oder schau mal hier zeig mal hier also ja super example alles klar ok ja dann ja
sollen wir recht sein ganz ehrlich reicht mir so ok das ist aber müll wie das formatiert
ist also wie musste man das jetzt richtig von der s print f ne s ne fmt s print f format
string ok prozent s hoffe ich mache das richtig so chat ergibt das sinn passt das so ist das
richtig ok also read ich habe es ich habe das doch schon geredet ok und jetzt gibt es
den fad ne moment ich muss das tatsächlich außerhalb außerhalb machen pass
so ok alles gut und dann geben wir den fad zurück weil hier müssen wir die datenbank
schreiben dass wir wissen was sache ist wo fehlen klammern da fehlt der klammern ok
wunderbar so also wir lesen sachen ein random laden das bild runter speichern das bild im
images folder wir machen leute wir machen mal nur wir machen mal nur fünf das reicht
erst mal ok so db create sparen wir uns auch sondern machen einfach nur fünf mal muss
ich das doch auch aus kommentieren mal einfach nur fetsch images prindeln moment warum gibt
es print line und und fmt print line ok so jetzt sollten wir fünf images bekommen wenn
das funktioniert was ich da gemacht habe vier images geht leute das funktioniert einfach
da guckt vier images pepo pepo fett images easy so und jetzt schreiben wir das jetzt schreiben
wir das in die datenbank jetzt schreiben wir das in die datenbank also fetsch images ne
wobei fetsch image ist eigentlich falsch ist aus fetsch image muss das heißen so fetsch
image uuid fetsch image so image world ist jetzt so wieso fakes du denn die daten eigentlich
weil ich zuerst gefaked habe bevor ich die api abgefragt habe ich hab die api erst später
gefunden für die bilder aber ich will das ja auch nicht eins zu eins aus der api übernehmen
und bei mir die datenbank schreiben oder so wann wozu ich will da gar nicht so viel den
da jetzt request schicken sonst muss ich am ende noch ein api key holen und ab dabei so
wir kriegen jetzt eine datenbank mit mit vier bildern mit vier mit vier einträgen schauen
wir mal ob das ob das muss ich noch safe oder sowas machen gorm muss man das muss man noch
speichern create muss ich noch sowas machen wie db safe einfach nur safe was
oder speichert er das oder speichert er das von alleine wenn ich da nicht safe safe callen
ok probieren wir mal kriegen wir jetzt eine datenbank alles klar schauen wir mal sqlite
browser food db warum genau hat er da so viele einträge ach so weil ich es vorher schon ein
paar mal habe laufen lassen und da unten sind die neue vier neue pepo fat food einträge
ok das ist nicht in memory man könnte in memory machen aber wir machen nicht in memory weil
dann wird bei jedem start wir machen das nicht in memory da wird bei jedem start diese food
api abgefragt und dann brauche ich irgendwann noch ein api key wir löschen die datenbank
mal und lassen da jetzt 100 100 100 sachen anlegen und fertig und gut ist ich überlege
gerade noch ist es sinnvoll was ist denn das beste format zum zurückgeben an in the web
api ohne punkt da vorne eigentlich eigentlich einfach nur so und das sollte er ja auch checken
wenn wir hier sind ok also go run machen wir mal machen wir mal eine anzeige wie weit wir
sind 100 lieber den leading slash ok wenn ich den leading slash hier mache dann muss
ich auf jeden fall noch ein punkt hier davor machen weil ansonsten schreibt er das nach
slash beruht was es nicht gibt bei mir ist jetzt zwar ein bisschen eklig zu lesen aber
ok alles klar x fatal für den sub also ran denn wir machen noch mal kurz fmt brindlen
was ok ich muss an diese format sonntags geben creating food item und jetzt prozent ok lasst
mich raten prozent d wie in c oder ist es prozent e das ist wahrscheinlich prozent e
das ist ein prozent v ne prozent v ist doch bestimmt in den blödsinn chat ja jebaitet
mich fmt print f au ist value ach ich mach das ja auch hier falsch es ist ja auch print
f ok print effeln gibt es nicht verstehe kein print effeln so ok lassen lassen wir den
mal ran 100 100 items creating food item flup flup flup flup flup flup flup flup nice sqlite
explorer was haben wir hier zeigt her wunderbar übrigens ich bin total bescheuert ich muss
es noch mal löschen ww root an das frontend zu liefern ist relativ bescheuert mein frontend
muss images sein und nicht ww root wtb nochmal weg fällt mir gerade ein ist eigentlich total
hängen geblieben so muss das sein so also das da das da muss eigentlich davor ansonsten
klappt das nicht gibt es was wie pass kombin ne pass ne warte warte ne go pass kombin
ich darf das hier nicht ich darf das hier nicht nicht pass nenn ich es fs pass oder
so das kann ich pass join pass join ist es das dann nämlich viel besser in dem fall ist
es ist wurscht aber so viel besser so f ww root images muss ich auch noch mal alle löschen
sich toll alle weg please 103 files flup return fs pass alles klar es ist nicht wirklich fs
pass das ist total bescheuert pass ne db pass image pass egal wenn das ist go land ich
habe dieses jet brains all desktop package deswegen verwende ich den ganzen fern ich
dann auch immer jet brain sachen wenn die was haben zumal die meistens auch was taugen
ok jetzt aber ich hoffe die blocken uns jetzt nicht beim api zugriff creating food item
sehr schön gut food item created browse data sehr schön guckte mal guckte mal da massive
100 100 food items spicy chicken soup with hint of lemon grass and coconut milk und dann
sinnloser random text ja die erhöhen den preis aber ich habe zum glück relativ lange laufzeit
noch aber ja es wird teurer leider gut also function fedge image das funktioniert so weit
passt gut also chat wir haben eine datenbank und jetzt brauche ich einen command line switch
gibt so was wie args oder sowas ich möchte das hier nicht jedes mal bei jedem start machen
ich möchte das eigentlich nur machen wenn ich einen speziellen command line switch angegeben
hab so minus minus sieht oder sowas go lang args command line args command line flex what
ist es mit so high iq flex string word for string also im prinzip eigentlich nur sowas
hier oder also also quasi sieht die fall value ist das hier wahrscheinlich falls usage was
ich sieht data data base and image directory sowas pointer ist sie mode ok if und dann machen
wir diesen kram nämlich nur ok das funktioniert nicht das ist ein pointer warum ist das ein
pointer blackpool ja also du musst nicht nicht nur so krass backseiten ich muss mir das erst
mal selbst überlegen und wenn ich da nicht draufkomme dann frage ich schon ist sie ist
das ein pointer warum ist das wo ist der sinn davon dass das ein pointer ist ach so das
ist ja ein objekt wo noch mehrere sachen drin steht aber trotzdem ok das passt ich hätte
eher gesagt dass man irgendwie sagen muss ist sieht mode und ks alda objekte hat das
nicht ich hinterfragt es jetzt einfach mal gar nicht ich nehme das einfach so zur kenntnis
dass das so funktioniert weil wenn ich das jetzt ausführe dann macht er nichts genau
so und wenn ich das siedeln will dann würde ich jetzt nämlich alles löschen nochmal also
sprich wir sagen wir sagen os remove os remove all ww root slash images remove denn an den
verzei remove der das verzeichnis oder nur das was drinne ist der rufe der macht das
ganze verzeichnis wahrscheinlich weg also muss ich sagen wie create muss ich dann wahrscheinlich
noch mal sagen moment create directory directory mk dir
ok das könnte sein dass das alles dass ich das alles mal wegschmeißen will aber noch
ein bisschen mehr so jetzt würde er wahrscheinlich alles wegschmeißen an bildern wird die datenbank
löschen wird die datenbank neu anlegen ja das sollte funktionen das ist aber auch ok
das passt jetzt haben wir eine datenbank mit ganz vielen mit ganz mit ganz viel food drinne
jetzt können wir uns mal der web anwendung wieder widmen also wir haben eine datenbank
achso hier muss ich dann vielleicht noch so wie return aufhören alles klar so wie hier
kriegen wir unser statisches unser statisches zeugs die filen die bilder und hier kriegen
wir ein random food aus der datenbank das heißt im endeffekt hier muss ich jetzt einmal
aus der datenbank random was auslesen wie lese ich random am besten aus der datenbank
was aus random also ich lese ich lese quasi ich gucke wie viel einträge sind achso wie
sieht das eigentlich aus haben die einen ordentlich durchnummerierten primary key nee achscheiße
nee doch da haben sie die haben eine id ich hoffe das ist eine id ist das eine id oder
ist das nee das ist einfach nur die einträge wie sieht das aus ich habe nicht wirklich
eine ahnung von datenbank aber was aber den primary key brauchst du doch was davon ist
denn jetzt der primary key name oh das ist eine gute idee zarex du hast recht ja das
machen wir besser so du hast du hast recht kurze mal im moment du hast recht aber es
braucht irgendwas muss doch der primary key sein oder aber das hier oben hin jetzt sagen
wir db kann ich eine datenbank droppen nachdem ich sie geopent habe ja ich muss hier erst
open auch openen dass ich sie droppen kann also würde ich dann quasi sagen die b nicht
dp dp dp drop nee was machst du was sagst du migrator drop table und food ok das ist
feifettig das ist das ist massive feifett gorm model ah das ist gut das ist gut zu wissen
dann will ich das haben dann dann will ich das haben was heißt das brauchen wir hier
gar nicht dann will ich das haben also sprich ich müsste das jetzt quasi erben oder was
also sprich gorm nee ok jetzt wird es advanced gorm model es hat eine row id das würde das
würde auch gorm id created ad aber sowas in gorm nee wie erbt man was in in in go geht
das überhaupt oder was heißt er oder sagen dass er das als interface also oder das interface
implementieren davon ok go lang implement interface
gorm models type user struct
also ich haue das einfach nur hier rein
und dann macht er das alles für mich oder wie ok da muss ich mich jetzt dran gewöhnen
das ist wirklich mal komplett anders wie sagen wir jetzt die scharpe oder so weil internet
wäre das relativ easy gewesen da hätte ich hier irgendwie sowas gemacht wie doppelpunkt
was weiß ich base model und dann hätte ich control alt gedrückt hätte gesagt implement
interface oder implement missing oder oder oder i base model oder was auch immer ok verstehe
alles klar das ist nicht schlecht das ist nice gut zu wissen da können wir auch gleich
checken comment können wir auch gleich checken ob unsere sieht function ordentlich funktioniert
also nochmal kurz durchgehen ob das sinnvoll ist also ich entferne erstmal alle images
aus www root images und dann lege ich das verzeichnis neu an dann drop ich die table
dann lege ich das alles neu an und dann ok also sprich minus minus wahrscheinlich muss
man so machen minus minus sieht ok aber warum erkennt er mein parameter nicht
reicht ja aber das müsste beides funktionieren oder ja dann sind wir sind mal so frei und
machen fmt prinden ist sieht mode was er dann sagt moment moment falls trotsch systems
ok warte mal go lang flex bool bool flex bool oder pass habe ich auch falls ah gucke mal
da also einfach so aha ja ja gut ok ok alles klar muss man wissen ergibt ergibt irgendwo
auch sinn wenn man es weiß sieht creating food item er hat die alten items gelöscht
und legt jetzt die neuen items an hoffe ich dass er das macht hoffe ich dass er das macht
images ist leer wie genau kann images leer sein
ey das wäre ich glaube nicht dass ich im ap rate limit bin ich meine wir können ja
mal hier ein bisschen ein bisschen debug ausgabe machen part stimmt nicht beim schreiben ja
aber warum freund hat er auch gestimmt ww root images ich will es jetzt nicht noch ich will
es jetzt nicht noch noch öfters ausführen weil sonst lande ich wirklich im
es ist eigentlich komplett richtig was der macht chat warum macht er denn so komische
dinge es ist nicht da soll ich mal das da weglassen wobei das ja eigentlich nichts damit
zu tun haben denn das kommt ja später
da der art der der htp requester wird schon funktionieren oder
ja warum sollte ich auch 100 machen ich stelle mal auf 2 runter das reicht ja auch
weil zumindest anlegen müsste das ok wir müssen jetzt doch mal wir müssen jetzt doch
mal er auschecken was er was er für schmerzen hat
ich meine von der idee müsste es ja funktionieren ww root images
macht er das denn ok vorher vorher hatte ich ja so stehen zwar zwar nicht schön aber
hat funktioniert was unter bild so egal also ich vermute tatsächlich jetzt auch vielleicht
haben wir echt api api rate limit oder so also wo haben wir denn die jason response
hier api root also das das hier scheint ja zu mal rückgängig das hier scheint wir
müssen jetzt wirklich die bank glaube ich was zum hä ich hatte das doch vorhin so
der springt dann gleich eins runter geht das ist pepega also wir setzen mal wie setzt
man hier breakpoint so ok also wir gucken mal rein an der stelle was add configuration
was hat er jetzt für schmerzen excellent alles klar go build
einfach so ja
so ja der geht ja da gar nicht rein moment ja not ok ok so jetzt ist die baga time angesagt
also was was ist denn jetzt was juju id ist alles klar das funktioniert
bites funktioniert auch das funktioniert das da ist das der macht da wirklich was
der müsste das anlegen und da schreibt auch was also leute bin ich im falschen verzeichnis
einfach nur jetzt blick ich aber echt nicht mehr durch warum wo ist denn jetzt das problem
juju id passt auch ich meine das hier ist ja das wichtig das in bites was drinne steht
also dating dating das ist das ist das ist dieses image image data das hat wohl funktioniert
an der stelle moment hä das muss doch was ganz offensichtliches sein dass ich ins falsche
verzeichnis schreibe oder so ich ist total hängen geblieben oder was ist denn hier los
os write files ok wir machen das mal anders home max wo sind wir denn hier wir machen
das wir machen das ja so dass er das gar nicht falsch schreiben kann so home max p
profet ww root slash so und dann images images und anders image hinten dran so ran
was ist das was so wie geht das in go so nee so
was doppelt slash wo ist doppelt slash was denn deswegen benutzt ja pass join dass er
das dass er das weg macht das sollte pass join ja schon checken dass es doppelt ist
so also fmt prindeln error falls wenn er haben geht das so macht man das so weiß nicht
ich weiß woran es liegt ich weiß woran es liegt guckt mal ich kann es euch sagen weil
es 600 das ist klar 600 permissions ist ja auch für ein ordner falsch ordner müssen
700 permission haben sonst funktioniert nicht wo wo leg ich den ordner noch mal an hier
hier mk dir da 700 muss das sein ordner brauchen immer execute rechte ohne execute rechte kannst
du in ordner nicht rein da wäre ich ja nie drauf gekommen jetzt heckl alter da ist es
ok passt meine güte das war jetzt das war jetzt schwere geburt so jetzt kann er wieder
ignorern alles gut er hat er hat sein ziel erfüllt ja ist so du musst du musst ja genau
funktioniert guckt ja du musst 70 du musst execute machen auf der also der user oder
die gruppe braucht execute rechte dass man in ordner rein kann ja er hat check wieder
weg ok fest das war jetzt wirklich schwer schwere geburt wir können übrigens noch was
machen man könnte man sich lieber nach wieder aus wie machen wir das guck mal wir machen
ich buhl wir machen ein int default value ist 100 so und und was ist denn das jetzt
muss ich jetzt sowas hier machen wie ist wait a minute wenn das jetzt ein optionales flag
ist wobei need and flag and flag kann doch gar kein int sein oder sonst wäre es ja kein
flag go lang flags int geht das geht tatsächlich flag int aber wie lese ich denn jetzt aus
ob das überhaupt gesetzt ist
das meine ich ja das ist kein flag das ist dann eher so eine option quasi das das das
meine ich nehmen also eigentlich müsste ich da zwei sachen draus machen doch du hast verpasst
dass wir jetzt die datenbank und datenbank gefüllt haben und bilder drin haben ja weil
jetzt ist die fall value 100 aber ich will ja nur ich will ich will es ja angeben können
oder nicht oder muss ich quasi dann sowas machen wie minus minus eins und dann checken
ob es ob es ob es nicht minus eins ist aber ich will es ja haben also sprich wenn ich
es angebe wenn ich das angebe dann will ich ja dass es default 100 weißt du was ich bleib
ich bleib bei buhl fertig aus äh die erste sprache ich hab relativ also ich hab mal vor
uhr uhr uhrzeit mal zehn bisschen gemacht aber da habe ich nichts mit anfangen können
das war aber ist ja auch keine gute einsteiger sprache und dann habe ich irgendwann mal mit
dotnet angefangen 2002 oder sowas einfach weil ich irgendwie weil es mich interessiert
hat und mich interessiert es bis heute noch mehr neue sachen anzugucken sonst würde ich
mir jetzt nicht irgendwelche go sachen geben ok also wir füllen jetzt die datenbank mal
ok stack overflow sagt flack command line look up actuals ok das ist das ist hochgradig
kryptisch also was flack command line command line look up ja aber stack overflow wenn
es stack overflow schreibt dann muss es richtig sein stack overflow liegt nie falsch genauso
wenig wie der twitch chat flack visit wait das ist noch was anderes
was zum das das ist das ist dass das hier finde ich tatsächlich die schönere variante
was was er schreibt also ok dann machen dann probieren was noch mal ist ist sieht mode
oder ist ist ja blöd ja sieht man äh int default value ist 100 und jetzt will ich checken
if also quasi das da if kommt da rein ok alles gut nachdem ich returne kann ich mit dem rest
sparen look up so so so wahrscheinlich so und dann
ist hier ah ne erst mal die die die referenzen wir machen mal zwei ob das funktioniert zwei
jetzt mal eine doofe frage warum muss ich denn da jetzt überhaupt was angeben wenn
ich doch in die fall value gesetzt habe ich wollte es eigentlich so machen dass ich dass
ich entweder so angeben kann er macht 100 oder ich gebe so an und dann macht das muss
ich mit zwei flex machen wahrscheinlich kommt er sagt er sagt die fall zwei aber wenn ich
nix angebe mag er es nicht die logik verstehe ich nicht was das sinn von default ist an
der stelle da kann ich nämlich einfach bei buhl bleiben aber es funktioniert prinzipiell
schon mal dass ich mich macht es rückgängig komm ja weg damit nicht so lange mit dem krempel
hier aufhalten so passt also alles klar so jetzt legen wir erst mal wieder die datenbank
an und machen jetzt mal mit der web anwendung weiter sqlite explorer gleich anschmeißen
gucken ob das alles passt gucken wir mal so also wenn jetzt hier in der in der datenbank
alles drin steht ach ja guckt mal jetzt ist der ganze krempel drin die id ist drinne created
ad ist drinne deleted flag ist drinne was bescheuert ist was wir gerade gar nicht brauchen
name vom essen ist drinne description vom essen ist drinne und ein link zum bild ist
drinne jetzt ist alles gut wunderbar so muss das sein
sehr schön gut dann können wir uns das jetzt ja sparen können wir den kram wieder ausführen
und gucken ob es passt ok so jetzt kommen wir mal zur web anwendung weiter im text nämlich
das was ich eigentlich machen wollte ankommen das ist eine gute frage ich gehe mal davon
aus dass da würde nicht funktionieren weil das ist ja meistens die kurzvariante also
sprich so oder halt also das minus s wäre kurzvariante ich glaube das müsste man wahrscheinlich
hier noch definieren bei dem weiß nicht ob der auch die kurzschreibweise definieren kann
kann man sich eigentlich die hilfe anzeigen lassen hier von jetzt string backseating chat
wie macht man hier von jetzt die kurzvariante das hier ist minus minus sieht und wie würde
ich jetzt definieren dass es minus s ist die kurzvariante wahrscheinlich einfach zweimal
flex wahrscheinlich müsste ich dann beides anlegen naja ok jetzt müssen wir random aus
der datenbank was auslesen irgendjemand hat gesagt es ist kein random order aber ich glaube
nicht dass wir das ich mein an sich ist die idee ziemlich cool da können wir auch gleich
mal gucken wie wir ein raw sql query darin absetzen können also wir kriegen wir surfen
alle files aus www root und haben einen endpunkt slash food so und wenn ich slash food aufrufe
mit curl dann will ich ein random food eintrag aus der datenbank zurückbekommen also data
ist db und was war das jetzt feind ne first ach first or create gibt es da auch aha also
sprich ich könnte abfragen und wenn es nicht da ist auch einfügen das finde ich ganz praktisch
gibt es sowas wie select sehr schön das ist gut wo haben wir denn noch mal die die gorm
die gorm hilfe seite hier select ok ich brauche mal ein beispiel query also take take one
record no specified order first id 1 ne order by id so last first row ich bin ich bin jetzt
gerade wie kriege ich da am besten ein random ein random wert raus ich meine ich könnte
gucken was ist die letzte id und dann in random aber schön schön ist es nicht oder
ok hier kann man auch die id angeben also ich könnte jetzt theoretisch sowas machen
ich meine ich weiß ja dass das 100 sind aber was ist das mit select es gab es gab es gibt
ja hier wohl irgendwie nen select was macht das select ach ne das sind die das sind wenn
ich nur verschiedene felder abfragen will also ne das ist was anderes also ich will
wahrscheinlich first haben ich will first food ok chat wie war das ich muss food verwenden
wenn ich es nicht initialisiere so und food so id und jetzt kommt was wo ich mir nicht
ganz sicher bin wie man das am besten machen random und wenn faker kann auch nen random
int ne ne math math random oder random random random random int random int ich will aber
doch sagen von bis go lang random int from to genau monka was
ist denn das das ist das jetzt soll nicht den hier in ernst oder das ist was es gibt
und es gibt int ach so moment int 31 ach so weil es exclusive ist oder wie int 31 also
die benahmung könnte man noch ein bisschen verbessern ich glaube die wollen uns sagen
weil es wahrscheinlich nicht inclusive null ist oder so man muss seinen random sieben
ne muss müssen muss man wahrscheinlich nicht geht bestimmt auch so also int und das ist
jetzt quasi also das das mag ich nicht ich mein warum warum können die das nicht ordentlich
benennen ich mein n warum steht da nicht warum steht da nicht zum beispiel sowas ab to n
inclusive oder sowas dass man wenigstens weiß was damit gemeint ist ok int first und jetzt
die id int ist jetzt das ist das inclusive null ist das inclusive 100 oder ohne 100 oder
in in inten int returns in int as non negative sorry ok also null ist dabei es ist null bis
99 quasi so das geht schon mal nicht null bis 99 weil wait a minute ah wir machen nur
100 ok null ist auf jeden fall ist auf jeden fall nicht ok also müssen wir quasi 99 machen
plus eins so dann kommt dann maximal 99 raus aber nie null das ist wichtig das ist das
allerwichtigste das ist bei go bei go und bei bei rust projekten dann ist es eigentlich
weniger wichtig ob was das projekt macht sondern ist wichtig dass gleich in der ersten
seite drin steht written in go written in rust also vor allem umso abgedrehter und seltener
die programmiersprache ist umso größer musst du das hervorheben dass es written in einer
speziellen programmiersprache ist ja das ist wenn wenn ich was ich was ich übergebe
minus null ist hier aber ich will ja sicherstellen dass es von 1 bis 99 ist inklusive nee muss
ich nicht weil es ist inklusive es ist exklusive 99 das heißt es kann maximal 98 plus 1 99
rauskommen irgendwann kommt noch go runtime written in rust das wird dann alles erfüllen
das wird dann alles erfüllen die rakete muss rein ganz wichtig das rakete das raketen emoji
ich genau die habe ich auch im titel event guckt euch mal guckt euch den stream titel
von heute an das ist der bescheid ja turbo charged ist auch sehr beliebt aktuell turbo
charges your development experience schreiben wir dann rein
turbo charging and blazingly fast ich habe nicht unendlich viel ram aber ich habe 32
gigabyte ram was gar nicht so wenig ist batteries included ja das gut dass das stand ja früher
sogar für die bei der pyson stellart library dabei ok also mal langsam ich habe jetzt
hier einmal food ausgelesen das heißt von der idee her wenn ich das jetzt starte nur
mal so dass ich dass ich jetzt nicht den faden komplett verlieren wenn ich das starte und
ich rufe jetzt hier mal ein food item ab sollte ich ein random food item bekommen das klappt
guckt mal leute pass mal auf wir gucken mal wie performant das ist ehrlich gesagt ist
hauptsächlich das terminal dass das das karl braucht mehr als das go guckt euch mal an
wobei denn die coolen leute verhörten ja betop mittlerweile ja guckt mal karl und betop machen
die cpu auslastung rest go go langweilt sich kann auch mal hardtop machen na ja go langweilt
sich na ja ok geht so kooper netus und nen sqlite cluster leute ein sqlite cluster und wenn
ihr sagt max ergibt keinen sinn doch das gibt es nennt sich github nennt sich so das
ist ein aufsatz für clustering von sqlite und hat 10.000 github sterne aber die idee
ist cool die idee ist wirklich nice man denkt bloß nicht dass es sowas gibt geklastert
ist sqlite ja ok wir können leute wir machen jetzt mal richtige richtige richtige auslastung
richtig richtig richtig auslastung aber jetzt mal hey 100 localhosts localhosts 80 80 o
ttp muster vor sp wange bob wange bob danke schön für den sub ok mal gucken wie hoch
die auslastung jetzt gleich ist 100 prozent cpu last aber ich mein es sind auch es sind
halt auch zwei millionen requests zwei millionen requests sind halt schon ein bisschen was
blazing fast leute blazing fast ok aber guckt mal als wir können es auch ein bisschen realistischer
requests oder 2000 requests oder mal mal 20 20.000 requests also wir kriegen wir kriegen
recht viel wir kriegen ordentlich viele requests durch guckt mal also hier guckt mal wir haben
summary pro request wir kriegen 39.000 requests die sekunde durch response time schwankt halt
ein bisschen aber tja von auszugehen aber die meisten haben kaum ach ja man muss ja
slash food hinten dran machen keckel alter ich nupe ist ja gar kein datenbank abfrage
dabei ja ok ist ein bisschen langsamer gewesen aber jetzt kriegen wir nur 17.000 requests
stimmt und es läuft sogar noch im debug mode leute das geht sogar noch schneller wir müssen
einfach sagen go run go run release mode wie macht man das auto bild nicht bild gibt es
in go überhaupt sowas debug und release builds gibt es sowas überhaupt also
es gibt es nicht ok also es ist immer es ist es ist es ist immer so ok also ich muss
nix ich muss nix machen also das heißt wir können uns das hier angucken ich kläre das
noch mal so ok also wir haben woops
you can remove simple and debug info das brauche ich jetzt nicht das ist beinahe ein bisschen
kleiner also wir haben 17.000 requests die sekunde ich würde sagen das ist in ordnung
zumal wir es ja vom gleichen rechner ausführen heute nächsten stream deployen wir das auf
die in die hetzener cloud und dann testen wir wie schnell es wirklich ist ok weiter
weiter im text also das ist also ich muss sagen geschwindigkeitstechnisch geht das geht
das durchaus in ordnung er hat 17.000 requests die sekunde ich weil wir machen ja auch nix
wir machen eine datenbank random randomized datenbank abfrage irgendjemand hat gesagt
ich muss mein random sieben wenn ich den nicht siede ist es dann immer null das können wir
relativ einfach ausprobieren ok so wir kriegen als erstes id 24 nochmal neu starten wir kriegen
all die 24 wait a minute ich muss wirklich den random generator sieden dass es nicht
immer die gleiche reinfolge ist warum macht er das denn nicht von sich aus auf der anderen
seite eigentlich eigentlich ist es gar nicht so schlecht ja alles was explizit da steht
ist keine magic unter der haube das ist ist ok lass ich lass ich mir gefallen also muss
ich muss ich jetzt hier erstmal so was machen wie renn sieht was war das unix nano ne nano
ok ich habe vergessen hier time now unix nano alles klar massive seed run ja jetzt ist es
auch richtig random also es ist vorher auch nein es ist nie richtig random und es war
vorher auch nicht richtig richtig random und es war vorher genauso random wie jetzt nur
dass er jetzt immer an einer anderen stelle startet oder mit einem anderen seed startet
ok wunderbar so also wir haben unsere food api am start euch das mal an unsere food api
gibt jetzt wenn man abfragt immer die id creator deleted name das den basilikum tomatensalat
mit einem bild dazu ich wette mit euch das bild ist definitiv kein basilikum tomatensalat
ist halt irgendwie random bild ok das funktioniert wunderbar jetzt müssen wir jetzt müssen
wir doch irgendwie mal checken ob wir das auf der webseite angezeigt kriegen müssen
wir back end technisch noch irgendwas machen nö oder passt doch eigentlich ach ja doch
ich will das doch eigentlich gar nicht an ans frontend ans ans frontend verteilen alles
von der lernkurve der dank dem fahrer high IQ pfeiffer chat alles in ordnung kann ich
dem irgendwie sagen dass er das ok go lang jason ignore ist das random 5 ja das haben
die damals diesen gag haben die damals gebracht zum debian random generator falls sich noch
irgendjemand an den kaputten random generator erinnert remove feels vom struct hiding jason
doppelpunkt minus kann man das so dahinter machen was warum muss man ok jetzt wird mir
die syntax aber ein bisschen abgedreht backticks jason doppelpunkt quotes minus also jetzt
haben sie es echt ein bisschen übertrieben so ein bisschen übertrieben ja aber es funktioniert
ok wir kriegen jetzt wirklich bloß nehmen kinder was sind kinder kalt essen die da irgendwie
kratzen oder was ne was sind was sind kinder kinder kalt deutsch laksalat sandwich ach das
ist irgendeine super markt kette kann das sein oder was ist das kinder kalt wer ist
kinder kalt das ist kinder kalt nein ich habe kein schimmer wer kinder kalt ist aber kinder
kalt ist also kinder kalt zu sein oder kalt kalt kalt kalt kalt kalt kalt kalt kalt kalt
Also jetzt unsere API macht jetzt schon mal was es soll, so wir kriegen ein Essen, sinnlosen
Text und ein Bild.
So jetzt müssen wir mal kurz gucken, dass wir das auf unserer Webseite angezeigt bekommen.
Leute ich mach keine Frontend Frameworks oder sonst was, das wird die billigste Webseite
die ihr je gesehen habt.
Auch hier im Stream.
Vor Spaces, eigentlich wollte ich Two Spaces, ich mach jetzt nicht Whistle Studio Code dafür
auf.
Wir machen kein Svelte, wir machen auch kein View, wir machen gar nichts, pepo fetter,
wir machen Script, Script, ich mach nie, ich mach nie in, für Frontend ist tatsächlich
Whistle Studio Code das was ich verwende.
Fetch, so Fetch, okay Fetch, Food, Await, ach Moment Top, gibt es schon Top Level Await,
Browser Support, ne oder das kann auch kein Browser, noch nicht.
Ja Moment Modules, Modules, doch, doch, doch gibt es anscheinend schon, aber nur in Modules,
ne Modules, ich weiß nicht mal wie man das macht, so, Kekl Alter, wir brauchen kurz noch
ein Browser hier, es wird langsam ganz schön voll, mal hier neben ausblenden, es wird langsam
unübersichtlich, Local Host 8080, pepo fetter alles klar.
Noch ne Debug, Konsole, das brauchen wir nicht mehr, Top Level Await, Ach Type, Module, okay
das hat funktioniert, Let, Response, Jason gleich, Jason Await, jetzt hab ich natürlich
noch nicht mal Auto Reload, Leute cooles Auto Reload Plugin für JetBrains Dinger, normalerweise
mach ich das wenn überhaupt mit dem Whistle Studio Code Dev Server oder eben mit dem was
im jeweiligen Framework eingebaut ist, es läuft, es läuft, alles gut, Log, Jason, hey es funktioniert
guck mal, wir kriegen unseren Crampel in Browser, Description und Images, alles klar.
Jetzt fällt mir wieder auf, dass ich von Raw Javascript absolut keinen Plan habe, wie macht
man denn jetzt sowas hier richtig, Div, mal ein bisschen Raw Javascript kann ja auch nichts
schaden, hallo, ich will, what the fuck, Div jetzt müssen wir ID's verwenden oder, hier
Title, Desk, ohje, jetzt, ohje das wird was, also, wie geht das jetzt, Document, Get Element
by ID, Name, Moment, Log, ja das funktioniert, alles klar, also, Element, so und jetzt Text,
ne, Inner Text ist es glaube ich, Inner Text gleich Jason Punkt Name, ok was habe ich falsch
gemacht, ach es heißt Name, da haben wir es doch, Name, Kalua Hot Chocolate, alles klar,
so Inner Text, dann brauchen wir noch, boah, Alter das ist ja eklig, Moment ich muss mal
kurz anders machen, Function, Set Text, Element Name, wir basteln uns jetzt ein eigenes JQuery,
nur in schlechter, weil ich keine Sachen verwenden will, Set Text, Name, ach so, ne, Sekunde,
ach fuck, Moment, ne, Text, Jason Dot Name, ok funktioniert und Description, Description,
ohje funktioniert, funktioniert ja, ist ja schonmal was, Unresolvable Vari, was, Laber
nicht rum, ok und jetzt kommt das wichtigste, das Image, Image, ne warte, wie mache ich
denn überhaupt, wie mache ich jetzt ein Image, denn, warte mal, Div, MonkaS Image, das muss
ich, muss ich selbst erzeugen, das Element und was da einfügen, ja, oh jetzt wirds,
jetzt wirds, jetzt wirds advanced, also sprich, ach ne, Image Source, du hast recht, stimmt,
das kann man ja tatsächlich setzen, Image, ID Image, weil man kann natürlich so machen,
das könnte man übrigens hier überall so machen, by the way, oder auch nicht, dann
halt nicht, ist ok, ist ok, ist gut, ist gut, Closing Tag ist redundant, wie darf man einfach
so Image schreiben oder was, ach so Source is required, das ist mir doch egal ob Source
required ist, ich will, document, getElement, by i, oh Gott, raw Javascript, image Source,
Source gleich Cackle, nur mal gucken ob es jetzt ein Fehler gibt, not found Cackle, schonmal
gut, schonmal gut, so, und jetzt Source, Jason gleich, wie habe ich den Campbell genannt,
Image Url oder so, Image Url, ach Moment, jetzt sind wir in den Javascript, jetzt macht
man ja wieder Semikolons, die können sich auch, warum gibt es kein super krasses übergreifendes
Sprachen Konsortium oder so, was einfach festlegt, ja macht gefälligst über, da ist es Leute,
guckt mal, also das ist übrigens, das ist ein griechischer Salat, falls ihr das nicht
erkannt habt, und das hier ist, das ist Chocolate Coconut Dreambars, falls, also die Bilder sind
mir bewusst, die passen nicht dazu, aber darum ging es ja auch nicht, so, wollen wir noch
so nett sein und es ein bisschen CSS stylen, weil das sieht jetzt halt schon mega beschissen
aus, blazingly fast Leute, blazingly fast, Favicon braucht kein Mensch, komm ein bisschen,
ein bisschen stylen können wir es noch, wie stylt man das so, Style, ne, Style, ok, Raw
not allowed hier, ok, style in head, ne, doch, OMG, also, Name is font size XXXlarge, jawoll,
so sieht jalapeño Pepper Jelly Chicken aus, ok, das könnte, ohne Mist, das könnte noch
am ehesten hinkommen von dem, was wir bisher hatten, ich mein, weißt du, ob da jalapeños
und ein Hähnchen vielleicht drin sind, kann doch sein, möglich, sieht zwar nicht so aus,
aber, dass das hier kein German Apple Cake ist, das sollte man glaube ich erkennen, das
ist nicht C-Line, das ist Goland, so, ok, jetzt haben wir schon mal eine Überschrift,
wir brauchen noch eine ordentliche Schriftart, wie macht man eine Default Schriftart so,
Body, Font, Family, ja hier areal, beste, ah ok, ja Roboto haben die wenigsten halt
installiert, wenn ich das halt, wenn ich halt Roboto schreiben würde, dann würden das halt
nur Leute bekommen, die Roboto installiert haben, ich bleib mal bei areal, areal haben
sie alle, so, als nächstes, nächste, nächste übrigens hier ist Description, Description,
ok, wenn wir mal, wenn wir mal XXlarge, und das ist XXlarge, nur nur XXlarge, alles klar,
ok, das sieht mega kacke aus, einfach nur large, ja ok, kann ich mitleben, margin, bottom,
2em, ein bisschen viel, was ist der Unterschied zwischen rem und em, das eine macht eben noch
dpi und das andere nicht oder, relative, ok, das sieht tatsächlich ganz brauchbar aus
jetzt, ein schönes was anderes, aber ok, wir machen das Bild, wir machen das Bild noch
ein ticken kleiner, image, so, image size, ok, das ist komplett mobile first, guck mal,
guck mal wie responsive, seht ihr das, guck mal wie responsive sich das an die Bildschirmbreite
anpasst, huge responsiveness, mehr responsive geht ja kaum, so, aber wir können noch das
image sein, wir können noch sagen, Breite von dem Bild ist, screen, ne, ne, wie ging
das, h-screen, ne, screen, v-screen, ne, ah ne, das war tailwind, 100 view war das richtige,
genau, komm mal jetzt, jetzt ist es richtig responsive, jetzt size, size das image mit,
das ist massive image, image resize, komm mal her, porgel, hide, hide, was, hide, auto,
ah, das ist nicht standardmäßig, kein unterschied, so, bam, also, massive, hier, nice food api
mit go, oh, you're blazingly fast, Leute, wollen wir mal gucken, wie schnell ich refreshen
kann, Achtung, wir testen das mal, blaze, oh Mist, blazingly fast, Leute, massive, huge
fast, also, okay Leute, ich geb zu, die Webseite ist sicherlich nicht die schönste, die es
irgendwie auf der Welt gibt, aber ich finde, durchaus ganz in Ordnung, ja, wie kriegt man
das Bild jetzt in die Mitte, wie krieg ich das Bild jetzt allein in der Mitte von der
Seite, normalerweise würde ich einfach Flexbox drumherum machen, aber, das dürfte tatsächlich
relativ easy sein, was, margin, null, geht das automatisch, ja, margin, null, auto, der
Chat ist high IQ, der weiß sowas, nee, geht nicht, reicht nicht, bringt nix, also, ich
dachte, wir könnten jetzt sowas hier vielleicht machen, if, was, und jetzt, jetzt soll ich
nochmal probieren, margin, null, auto, wenn der Chat das sagt, dann klar, nee, geht immer
noch nicht, ich hätte jetzt gesagt, wir machen jetzt hier sowas, pass mal auf, wir machen
jetzt inline style, Flex, nee, wie hin das überhaupt, ich kenn bloß noch die Tailwind-Abkürzung,
ich weiß gar nicht, wie man ordentliches normales Flexbox macht, ach, Display Flex, Flex, so
und jetzt muss ich items, align, Flex, align, heißt das so, nee, nee, align, align items,
center, align content, center, bin mir gar nicht sicher, ob das, okay, das funktioniert
nicht, weil ich zu blöd bin, normales TSS zu machen, aber so müsste man das eigentlich
machen, wenn man jetzt noch wüsste, wenn man jetzt noch die richtigen Sachen wüsste,
ja, justify content ist es, justify content, ah, ja, yes, excellent, so ist es, genau,
so, beste Image Random Mizer Seite überhaupt und ich sag euch, demnächst wirds in die Cloud
Deployed mit Clustered SQLite Datenbank für noch mehr Placingly Fast Performance, ja,
also was haben wir denn gelernt, lasst doch mal gucken, wir haben gelernt, wie man in
Go einen Web Server macht, da fehlt noch, was fehlt noch, das Favicon fehlt ja aber
ich hab doch gar keins, also du meinst, ich muss einfach noch die Rakete auf die Seite
machen, du meinst, ich soll, okay, okay, okay, ist gut, das muss sein, ja, ihr habt recht,
gewisse Sachen sollten so sein, ja, wo macht man das hin, hier in Het, Favicon, ja, das
ist, jetzt sagt er mir wahrscheinlich, dass er es nicht laden kann, ist ja klar, will
plus wissen, ob er es nicht laden kann, ja, so und jetzt Rocket Emoji Rocket, ja, welche
nehmen wir denn, Twitter, Twitter Emojis, beste oder welche Rakete, oh guck mal, Skype ist
sogar animiert, ja, das ist Twitter, was wir im Chat haben Leute, das ist Twitter, das
ist das da, Achtung, CD, WWW Route, WGET, MV Rocket 2, wie hab ich gesagt, ja nicht
SVG, Alter, PNG, und, achso, PNG, zack, Leute, Rakete am Start, also jetzt ist, jetzt ist
es kaum noch zu übertreffen, es ist noch Plasingly Faster, Roasted Broccoli, okay,
wo genau, okay, also lass mal kurz gucken, was, was, was haben wir gelernt, wir haben
gelernt, wie man bei Goan einen Webserver macht, also im Prinzip haben wir alles hier
gelernt, weil ich keine Ahnung davon hatte, so macht man den Goan einen Webserver, registriert
sich, jetzt aber Chat noch mal eine andere Frage, was genau ist jetzt der Vorteil davon,
irgendwelche Frameworks zu verwenden, also mal genommen, ich würde so was wie Fiber
oder so verwenden, was wäre jetzt der Vorteil, dass ich beispielsweise nicht mehr jeden einzelnen
Schritt wie, wie Jason Serialize von Hand machen muss oder Header setzen von Hand machen
muss und so was, ja, okay, ich verstehe.
Ja, okay, ja, alles klar, verstanden, ja, leuchtet ein, also wir haben geguckt, wie man,
wie man einen Webserver startet, wie man Routen registriert, wie man random Zeugs macht, wie
man Jason Serialisiert deserialisiert, wie man eine Datenbank mit einem ORM Mapper verwendet,
man Header setzt, wie man statische Files surft, wie man eine Datenbank seedet, dass
der Ordner 7.0 Berechtigung braucht, dass es in Go drei verschiedene Sachen gibt Variablen
anzulegen, wie man Jason Ignore ganz ehrlich, also da haben sie echt übertrieben, das ist
ja mal wirklich absolut reudig des Sonntags, da muss ich sagen, in.NET hätte man das
so gemacht, nur mal so als Beispiel, dort hätte man sowas gemacht, was ich irgendwie
schöner finde, als das da, das ist wirklich eklig, dass man Errors nicht braucht, korrekt,
bloated Errors, das nächste Mal dann Kontext für Timeout und Cancellation, ja, wäre vielleicht
gar nicht so schlecht, jetzt nicht, es gibt jetzt auch noch gerade hier nicht viel was
Timeouten kann, nix längeres aber, so wie man HTTP Requests macht haben wir gelernt,
wie man Files speichern in Go haben wir gelernt, dass man ganz schön viele Imports braucht
Packages habe ich gelernt, na das muss man halt sagen, in dem Fall, wir hätten, wenn
wir sowas wie ASP.NET Core verwendet hätten, wir hätten nichts an Zusatzpackages gebraucht,
das wäre eingebaut, das wäre eingebaut, doch doch, Faker, Bogos hätten wir gebraucht,
ja das hätten wir gebraucht tatsächlich, ansonsten halt keine, moin Michi, lieber CSS
landen, du brauchst, um CSS ein bisschen kommt man nicht drum herum, ich meine, ich habe
auch keine große Ahnung von CSS, guckt euch das hier mal an, da habe ich mir schon schwer
getan, aber, ähm, ein bisschen Ahnung, wie man was macht ist nicht verkehrt, ich persönlich
mag ja Tailwind, weil es CSS ist, aber halt nicht ganz so painstampig zu schreiben wie
CSS, aber sowas wie Bootstrap ist auch nicht verkehrt, aber ein bisschen CSS, so wie man,
ähm, beispielsweise, so was weiß ich, wie man Grid macht oder wie man Flexbox verwendet
oder wie man was zentriert und sowas, das sollte man sich schon mal angucken, weil das
wird man bei Bootstrap auch ab und an brauchen, das kenne ich, das wird aber leider nicht
mal weiterentwickelt, das letzte Update war von 2014 oder so, ja, siehste, da gibt es
mittlerweile, gibt es mittlerweile neuere Sachen, haben wir das geforkt oder was, ja,
es gibt, CSS Sachen gibt es massig und selbst Bootstrap, ich meine mit Bootstrap hat dieser
ganze CSS Framework Sachen, Kram so richtig angefangen, aber es gibt ja so viele Sachen
mittlerweile, was CSS Frameworks gibt, ähm, stimmt wohl, da gibt es Tausende mittlerweile,
ja, und manche, manche sind auch noch irgendwie Framework spezifisch, also es gibt, allein
für React gibt es ja schon irgendwie 20 verschiedene CSS UI Frameworks, gut, das ist dann die Kombination
aus CSS und React Komponenten, für Vue gibt es auch ein paar, ähm, also da gibt es so
viel, ich glaube, wenn man nach CSS, Moment, da gibt es doch bestimmt ne Liste von, List
auf, oh, es war so klar, dass es da schon wieder irgendeine Liste von gibt, ja, Agile Content
Management, wunderbar, Pog, furchtbar akil alles, ich mein, guckt euch das mal an, das,
es gibt so viel, ok, Moment, es gibt classless, ok, classless bedeutet im Endeffekt, das
style die Default Elemente und alles andere musst du selbst machen, dann hast du very
lightweight, das sind die, da musst du selbst classless eintragen, aber, du musst dich
selbst darum kümmern, und dann hast du general purpose, da ist ein Bootstrap dabei, Foundation
sind dabei, UIKit, ich dachte, UIKit ist, ist, ist, ähm, React, oder, bring ich das
jetzt durcheinander, ne, anscheinend nicht, doch immer, Foundation, Foundation gibt es
richtig lang, Foundation war damals so ein bisschen die Konkurrenz zum Bootstrap, das
gibt es schon seit, seit 10 Jahren, oder so, Carbon Components, das ist die Microsoft
Geschichte, gell, Carbon Components, ah ne, IBM, IBM, ich hätte ja auch nicht gedacht,
dass IBM mal ein CSS Framework hatte, Fomantik, Pico CSS, Blaze, UI, Base, Turret, Vanilla
Framework, Material Design Framework, ok, Tailwind ist tatsächlich cool, das passt
hier gar nicht so wirklich rein, weil man muss halt CSS machen, nur, dass es ein bisschen
besser zu schreiben ist, und das sind, bei weitem, noch nicht alle, wette ich mit euch.
Ja, so, ich bin jetzt 3 Stunden 45 on, ich glaube, das reicht für heute, morgen früh,
ihr müsst aufwachen, streamen, wieder wie immer, so kurz, so kurz vor 9 um 9 um, eigentlich
wollte ich noch ein Video machen heute, aber ich glaube, jetzt ist es ein bisschen spät,
wir haben 7 Uhr, 17 Uhr 5, ich wollte eigentlich ein Video heute machen, das, das habe ich
euch ja gestern kurz erzählt, ne, also, YouTube ist gerade der Meinung, mein Windows 11 Video,
ne, das da, die promoten das gerade, wie verrückt, das hat innerhalb von paar Tagen irgendwie
50.000 Views bekommen, oder so, oder ob drauf, also, das hatte vorher schon irgendwie so 60k
oder so, 60, 70k, und jetzt geht es voll ab, und hier schreiben so viele Leute, ich will
auf Linux, ich will auf Linux und sonst was, und ich wollte einfach ein Video machen, dass
für viele Leute Linux nicht die Lösung ist für ihre Windows Probleme, viele Leute erwarten,
dass quasi dann, dass sie dann quasi ein Windows bekommen, ohne die Probleme von Windows,
aber das ist nicht so, das ist ein komplett anderes System, und wenn man sich nicht darauf
einlässt, dass das ein anderes System ist, dann wird das auch nichts, die meisten Leute
wären tatsächlich, wenn sie keinen Bock mehr auf Windows haben, und einfach was haben wollen,
was funktioniert, und wo sie auch, ja, vielleicht ein bisschen Videoschnitt und Krams, vielleicht
Programme, die sie schon haben, weiter verwenden können, teilweise, da sind die wahrscheinlich
wirklich, wenn sie keinen Bock haben auf Windows, mit Mac noch besser bedient als mit Linux,
was cool an Mac ist, dass es eine ganz nette Kombination ist aus sinnvollem User Interface,
aber auch halbwegs gutem Unix Unterbau, also du hast ein ordentliches Terminal, du hast
deine Shell Befehle, du kannst vieles im Terminal machen, du hast einen ordentlichen Package
Manager fürs Terminal, also aus den Gesichtspunkten ist Mac OS um vielfaches besser geeignet für
Windows Umsteige erstmal als Linux, man kostet was, und mittlerweile brauchst du halt auch
wahrscheinlich, ja, an Apple Hardware kommst du ja im Endeffekt auch nicht vorbei, das
heißt, ja, geldtechnisch ist so ein Ding, das Jahr des Linux Desktop ist höchstens
in WSL, Apple Hardware ist arm CPU, ja, und man ist arm, wenn man sie gekauft hat, glaube
ich nicht, das glaube ich nicht, ja, das sind aber wahrscheinlich auch nicht so die Leute
mit dem typischen Windows Workload, also die typischen Windows Benutzer, das sind ja nicht
welche, die nur Mails lesen, also Leute, die wirklich nur Mails lesen und surfen, die kommen
wahrscheinlich mit einem Tablet heutzutage aus, ja, ich glaube die meisten Windows User
haben so eine relativ durchwachsene Userverhalten, die wollen ab und zu mal Fortnite spielen
oder ein paar neue Spiele auf Steam spielen, vielleicht wollen die irgendwelche Adobe Programme
verwenden oder ein paar Video, Bilder, Sachen zusammenklicken, dann wollen sie vielleicht
den Fitness-Tracker anschließen, sie wollen ihr Telefon sünden und solche Dinge, also
wenn die wirklich nur surfen und so, dann ist das alles kein Problem, dann kommst du
mit mehr oder weniger jedem Betriebssystem hin, was ein Browser hat, aber wie gesagt,
ich glaube die meisten Windows User machen halt eher das, was ich gerade gesagt habe,
und da wirst du über kurz oder lang, wenn du rangehst an Linux mit, es ist ein besserer
Windows Ersatz, nicht glücklich, weil es ist kein Windows, es ist auch kein Windows Ersatz,
allein schon das der 0815 Anwender Angst hat vom Terminal, und warum hat der Windows der
0815 Anwender Angst vom Terminal, wegen diesem Ding hier unter Windows, weil Microsoft diesen
Rotz hier ausliefert seit Jahren, mittlerweile gibt es aber zum Glück was besseres, und
die Leute Panik bekommen, wenn sie dieses Fenster sehen, ich denke auch, dass vielen
heute tatsächlich ein Tablet reicht, und ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass sogar relativ
viele Leute nicht mal mehr ein Desktop PC haben, die machen alles übers Tablet, für
ganz normale Leute, die vielleicht sogar in diesem Apple Kosmos leben, die ein iPhone
haben und ein iPad haben, vielleicht ein Apple Fitness Zeug, die kommen damit auch wunderbar
klar, und selbst mit einem Android Smartphone, du kommst theoretisch relativ gut klar ohne
Desktop, zumindest so die 0815 Sachen, ja doch Anti-Cheat ist tatsächlich schwierig,
es sei denn es ist Anti-Cheat, was ein bisschen da mitspielt, und ich glaube BattleEye spielt
mit, und der Valve Anti-Cheat spielt halbwegs mit, wenn du sowas wie Valorant probierst,
oder ganz abgedrehte Sachen, mail.ru Anti-Cheat, wir gucken mal, ProtonDB Valorant, Valorant,
ach Moment, das sind nur Steam, ok das ist ja nur Steam, Moment,
ach wird nicht aktualisiert, aber kannst du wahrscheinlich vergessen, der Typ, it's fun
when it works, ja, das Problem dabei ist halt auch, dass du dich nicht darauf verlassen
kannst, dass es funktioniert, wenn du Windows hast, kannst du Steam, Epic Store, GOG, es
gibt GOG, gibt es übrigens glaube ich auch nicht für Linux, kannst du dich halt drauf
verlassen, du kaufst ein Spiel, installierst das Spiel und das geht, und bei Linux kannst
du sagen, ja es gibt viele Spiele, die funktionieren, aber wenn du ein neues Spiel kaufst, das ist
dann erstmal, du kannst dir halt nicht sicher sein, ja, deswegen denke ich die meisten Leute
sind relativ schnell wieder unter Windows, wenn sie das als Windows Ersatz nehmen, sie
einfach nur sagen, ja ich will halt ein Windows, was nicht die Windows Probleme hat, ja, ja
Gott, der hat recht, du hast dann halt auch immer so Leute, ich will es jetzt gar nicht
unterstellen, dass das nicht stimmt, ja, aber ich kenne das, gerade auf Reddit und in Foren,
dann posten die Leute sowas wie, das und das funktioniert bei mir nicht, da kommen als
ersten Antwort immer, als Antwort so, also ich weiß nicht, was bei dir los ist, aber
bei mir funktioniert das alles in den höchsten Settings ohne Probleme, war im Wald PogChain
doch, war schon morgen schon, die Sache ist halt einfach, dass du dich nicht drauf verlassen
kannst, das ist schon allein für die meisten Leute dann nicht brauchbar, weil wenn du dir
ein Spiel auf Steam kaufst, den die Leute gewöhnt, du klickst auf install und du spielst
das und musst nicht erst noch eine Woche warten oder vielleicht irgendwelche krassen Hacks
und Tweaks machen, dass es funktioniert, das ist jedes mal so ein bisschen Zitterpartie,
ja, neues Release gehts oder gehts nicht, klar es geht schon viel mehr als es noch vor
10 Jahren ging, keine Frage, aber immer noch nicht genug, alles Pog aktuell, nee, der Typ
hat das ganz gut zusammengefasst, wenns geht ist es gut, problematisch ist nur wenns nicht
geht, Twice Baked Potatoes, ja so sieht das aus, alles klar, das kann aber auch nur so
viel machen wie es machen kann, dort muss es erstmal Hacks geben, es muss erstmal bekannt
sein, dann müssen sie ihre Datenbank updaten, es gibt vieles was man machen kann, aber es
ist einfach weit davon entfernt zu sagen, jawoll ich kauf das und kann mich dann drauf
verlassen, dass es geht, es ist eher so, ich kauf das und ich denke mit ein bisschen Glück
gehts, ne Switch, was hat denn jetzt die Switch mit dem Steam Deck zu tun, das Steam Deck
ist ein PC mit Steam OS drauf und die Switch ist eine Nintendo Konsole mit eigenen Spielen
dafür, Pog ist verfügbar, danke falls du gesagt hast ich habs übersehen, also es ist
halt ein bisschen Paynes Champ noch, bei anderen Sachen, ich weiß nicht wie es aussieht wenn
es Leute gibt die tatsächlich sagen, ich hab irgendwie ein Adobe Abo und will den Kram
unter Linux verwenden, ich hab keine Ahnung ob das annehmbar läuft aktuell, ich würde
darauf tippen nicht und spätestens wo es aussteigt ist wahrscheinlich wenn du dann
mit GPU rendern willst oder sowas, es ist halt so ein Zitterding, du weißt nicht ob
es geht, Leute die beispielsweise ihre Steuersoftware verwenden, da wäre ich vorsichtig ob ich die
über Wine laufen lassen würde, die meiste Steuersoftware ist ja 0815 Windows Anwendung
die ganz gut laufen, aber ganz ehrlich, ich weiß nicht ob ich bei sowas risikoreichen
irgendwie Steuern riskieren würde, dass das irgendeine Library nicht richtig lädt und
vielleicht nicht ordentlich rechnet oder was weiß ich, ne ich würde einfach, ich würde
das Sache nicht trauen, dass 100%ig das richtige Ergebnis rauskommt, ja oder, also deswegen
das ist ja das was ich sage, wenn du alles im Browser verwendest, dann ist nahezu egal
welches Betriebssystem du verwenden, da können sogar Tempel OS, wobei hat Tempel OS, hat
das einen Browser, Tempel OS Browser, haben die sowas, oh Moment Tempel OS ist, GNU mag
Tempel OS nicht, was ist da los, ne es gibt keinen, es gibt keinen Browser auf Tempel
OS, ja Jesus braucht keinen Browser, da Spring braucht das Tempel OS auch nicht, so Leute
4 Stunden bin ich am Start, passt auf die Sekunde, ich gehe jetzt off und wir sehen
uns morgen früh spätestens, bis dann machts gut, see you.